Welcome back, Master and Miss!
Hello, everybody.
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid 4!
Spooky number.
Lucky, lucky.
Evening, boss.
Evening.
Metal Gear.
Welcome back, welcome back.
Today we're doing Act 2 of Metal Gear Solid 4, Guns of the Patriots.
What shenanigans shall we get into today?
Sorry, my... I'm very... like... today.
No!
Mew!
I had a dream I sent you my first rainbow super chat, so here you go.
Can I have a healing beam?
I'm sick!
Feel better!
Oh my gosh, Mew, don't, please don't.
Thank you!
Feel better, beam!
I'll send you lots of energy.
Lots of moe magic!
Panic!
Thank you for the five gifts!
I feel like I'm still kind of getting over...
what I've... the boonkidus I had a while ago.
Thank you, Mew!
Letter M, letter I, letter N, letter T, letter O.
Mewto!
Boonkidus can take a while, give it time.
Yeah, it's really just like I have a...
It's just I have a cough still, but it's okay.
Darkray, thank you for the ten gifted!
Mew, thank you!
Oh gosh.
Rainbow N.
We had the I.
Wait a minute!
No!
Did I do yellow yet?
Yes, I did.
Yes, I did!
Love Mewto, no matter what flavor she is in.
Everybody was talking about Blue Mewto.
I did a... I was a caster, co-caster.
With Doki for...
Minecraft MOBA yesterday.
Mewto!
Thank you Mew!
Thank you for the rainbow!
Thank you.
And...
Everyone was just like, oh my gosh, why are you blue?
It's because...
They couldn't do chroma key very...
They couldn't figure it out very well.
Doki, thank you for the five gifted!
I don't know how I became blue.
But they couldn't figure it out very well.
I wasn't streaming... I wasn't doing anything, rather.
Like, everything was being handled on their side.
So, I was just kind of like...
Alright...
And I've turned blue!
So, we unlocked a new Mewto skin yesterday.
Maybe.
One you'll probably never see again.
And here goes, thanks for the 20 gifted!
Oh!
Just like how we got Otakons.
We did miss the briefings last time.
Maybe we should...
Maybe we should watch them this time.
Busy last time GS4 stream, but today you got my full attention!
Okay.
Game plus save, you can usually unlock hidden items via passwords in the extras menu.
Easily findable on GameFAQs.
Is GameFAQs still around?
Popo's Mewto.
Pepecore, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Blue Mewto is more Kusogaki than normal Mewto.
What!?
It literally is me!
It sure is.
Wow.
GameFAQs will never die.
I guess so.
Extras, there was free DLC items.
Worth googling off stream.
Thank you!
Thanks Chikado.
Chikado.
Avocado.
Shall we do the vision briefing then?
And grab...
What's it called?
The... Oh wait.
It should work.
It should still let me pick which one, right?
Marco, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you.
I hear she's pretty good.
Let's see.
So, okay, hold on.
I wanna explain something too before we start.
Because I made up a bit of an oopsie.
I, as you can see, we still have 287,200 Drebin points.
And I looked up the best places to farm Drebin points.
Because I was just like, oh yeah baby.
Let's get us some Drebin points so that we can get to 5 million.
Right?
And...
As you can see, we are starting Act 2.
We are at the Act 2 briefing.
Right?
But...
I looked it up and this place.
This place right here.
At the beginning of Act 2 is one of the best places to farm.
Because there's a frog unit girlies that drop really good to sell weapons in this spot.
And then...
Spoilers Minto.
I have to explain it.
But then...
The other places that are the best places to farm aren't until like Act 4 or 5.
So I would have to play until the end of the game.
Unless I do farming here.
So...
Minto, Minto never changes.
She's always cute.
Stop it.
Cervantes, thank you for the super chat.
I played MGS3 and didn't actually play it for a year because Japanese games don't use the normal action key.
I thought it was broken.
I know what you mean, Panic.
It confuses me so much too because I feel like I'm constantly having to switch my brain.
I feel like I'm constantly having to switch my brain.
But anyway...
So...
I was like, oh my gosh, I can do like a membership stream and we just farm for a couple hours and see how much we get.
I didn't...
I completely dropped the ball.
I completely dropped the ball on doing that.
So...
I'm still gonna play Act 2 today.
But...
I'm going to save on a different file.
So that...
In the middle of the week, I can go back and farm on stream.
And then...
And then I'll play through it again.
And then I will resume next week.
I'll resume next week.
Normal.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the superchats!
Let's go EU friendly streaming time.
Crimson, thank you so much for a month of membership.
Like 10 superchats and I only use them on you.
Big love from Denmark.
Thank you, Salken!
Everyone in chat, farming stream sounds great.
Minto, I'm going to make my life harder for no reason.
I want to play the game!
I don't want to just farm today.
I want to...
Because then, next week we would have to play...
The whole Act 2.
How long do you need to farm?
I don't know!
I don't remember how much the weapons they drop or how much they sell for.
But it's...
They drop big money.
Not big, big money.
Like it would probably still be a good amount of farming, I feel.
Try for a little bit to see how it goes.
Maybe, yeah.
Maybe we'll do that.
But...
But I...
I think this Act is already quite long.
I mean, they all are pretty long.
It also depends on how well I play.
I don't know!
I guess if you are a VOD watcher, you will potentially know how this goes.
I think.
Another month by the pinky!
Thank you!
Also, D2R3K, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Farming stream, I love me some Story of Seasons.
Looking forward to Dystopian Militaries Farming Simulator 4.
Hello VOD watchers, how's the future like?
That's great!
They're watching...
They're watching Minky's stream.
Oh!
I also wanted to talk a little bit about...
Yesterday was Fuwamuko's birthday.
And one of the songs, Kanashimi Calibration.
There's a part in the middle where it's kind of quiet.
But it's not quiet because you hear a bunch of people yelling.
And I was one of those people yelling!
Yelling!
I can't believe they did Omyoji.
I can, because...
I mean, they started with Party Night.
Fuwamuko has amazing, amazing, amazing peak taste.
Obviously.
I was there!
Yeah, kind of.
They contacted me a couple months ago about it.
Actually, it's funny.
They asked if I could record it.
Me doing the mix, and I was just like, yeah!
They were like, if you don't have time to, you know, record...
If you are back in Japan soon, you can come to our studio.
I was like, oh my gosh, I almost went to the Hololive studio to record.
But luckily, I was recording that day, because I actually...
Or rather that week, I was recording...
I actually recorded me doing that the same day that I recorded Phantom Pain.
For Touhou Lost Word.
So I recorded all of Phantom Pain.
It took me like three hours, and then I was just like, okay, time to mix.
So it was all, same day!
And so I've been just kind of sitting on it, being so excited, because I love Kanashimi Calibration.
Honestly, I had to relearn the mix, because I was like, it's not a mix that you ever get to do, except outside that song.
And the group has disbanded a long, long time ago.
So...
No, they didn't do any Denpogumi songs.
But that's okay, they did a whole Denpogumi karaoke.
But yeah, so I just, you know, if you haven't watched their live yet, it was so...
I was crying so much.
I was like, oh my gosh, it was just such a...
It was like, oh my god.
It was...
You could really tell how much work they put into it, and...
I was so...
You know, obviously I was so honored that I could be even just a little fraction, a part of it.
But, oh my gosh, they're just so...
They're just such hard-working sisters.
I love them so much.
And...
Yeah, it's a really, really good show that they put on.
And it made me really motivated, too.
So, hopefully, you know, I can do a birthday live like that one day.
And...
Yeah, hard-working doggos, I know!
As soon as I saw the song, I was telling my Discord friends, I bet Mint is losing it right now.
And then you were in the song, and I was losing it instead!
I flipped your expectations!
But...
Found something interesting on Twitter regarding Metal Gear.
Someone was showing how to repair a little Metal Gear, and David Hater commented that he'd just keep destroying it!
Sasuga, David Hater.
He's so great.
I love how interactive he is with the fans.
And everybody... He still loves Metal Gear.
He's done so much!
That guy is literally, like, a crazy screenwriter.
And yet, he's still interacting with little ol' us.
Little ol' Metal Gear fans.
Lampy, thanks for the gifted!
I'd love to see y'all collab and just gush about idols.
That would be fun.
I just wanted to bring that up too, because it was yesterday.
Sorry, it's not related.
He loves talking about X-Men as well.
Yes, he does.
He loves bringing up scenes.
He's like, um, I wrote this scene.
And it's like, peak cinema.
And you're like, okay, genius.
Mr. Hater.
You're crazy.
Howdy howdy, Morning Minto.
Howdy howdy.
He's so cool.
He really is so cool, right?
Gosh.
Man!
Anyway, okay.
So, um, is this...
This is...
What did I click on?
Hold on, I'm just gonna load this.
Yes.
What did I load?
Okay.
Thanks for the stream, Minto.
Perfect background noise for my Foxhound rank attempt is negative.
Good luck, Briar.
One Liquid Sun mission briefing.
We didn't do it last week.
And let's get Campbell's face, right?
Let's steal his face.
We can watch it real quick.
Just a little recap, right?
Kind of a bit of a recap.
Of the story.
And the mission.
And everything.
Mission briefing.
But I won't do this every stream, obviously.
Time to lock in.
What?
We watched this one.
Sunny.
So quiet.
He's so colonel.
I once heard his voice in another video game.
And it's literally just like, I can't hear anyone else.
Wait a second.
Bears.
Teddy bears.
The framerate.
Ben 10 uncle, yeah!
Is he here?
Okay, good.
Look at little Mark 2.
Stop being mean to Sunny!
That's the worst part of this game, is they're so mean to Sunny.
Look at her, she's just like a maniac.
How's the audio by the way?
Eat the edge.
Throw it at them.
Look at her, she's about to lose it.
Naturex.
Nature protein.
Why does colonel look like that?
You're so mean to her!
I can't even concentrate on the conversation.
They're so mean to Sunny.
She has to walk up the steep stairs.
I'm gonna die so bad!
Oh my god, you're so horrible.
Eat the eggs!
This part is so sad.
Sunny!
Someone's in trouble.
You go tell him Sunny.
Snake!
You were smoking again, weren't you?
This is a non-smoking play!
Stomp him.
Crush him.
Did we get the gold?
Tap him.
Cute.
So clumsy.
Bonk, grandpa.
How do I get to use it?
Let me use the robot.
Get in the robot, Minto.
Minto.
This is a good summary.
This is a good recap though.
Is Snake somehow older than Colonel?
It's an accelerated aging.
So he's numbers younger, but probably...
His body is older.
Sad.
Nurse.
Perceptor and Ares Transformers.
Ride and jump scare.
He's got such big eyes.
He's just like, please sir, may I have some more gunpowder?
Please sir.
No way.
This is so awesome.
The logo is so awesome.
Wait, how do I select the button?
Come here Colonel.
Got it.
We got it.
I heard it.
Oh Snake.
Sunny!
Look at her go.
Oh sorry, here you go.
Now you can see her.
Oh Sunny!
She's being sneaky.
Am I in your way?
L2.
I see.
Is there anything else around here?
Chickens.
Where did the teddy bears come from?
They are so cute.
Nice.
That's why you zoom around a little bit.
Cinema.
Solid as chicken.
Oh iPod.
That's right.
Do we have time to get it?
Let me out.
Oh my god.
Zoom in.
Ration.
Where is it?
Got it.
She looks like a cat.
What is she doing?
Ok, we'll go back to the scene now.
What's that picture of?
That one up there?
It's Olga.
Ok Sunny.
What the?
I got Sunny's face.
It's a little freaky, isn't it?
Olga, do you have Metal Gear Solid 2?
Sunny again.
There we go.
Ok, so that's why we just did the last mission.
Rat Patrol.
They were sneaky.
Liquid's looking at you.
He's peeping.
I can vouch for them personally.
And we learned that it's Meryl and all then.
Johnny Meryl.
Oh, I didn't even realize she left.
Sunny, hold on.
Hold on.
There she goes.
This is quite the angle.
Sorry.
There she goes.
Up you go.
Will you terminate liquid?
Thank you, thank you.
Mint toy Oh my god.
The pixelated liquid.
He's so pixelated.
But if you're going to spark something, spark this.
Snake Even Colonel is like, come on man.
Spark this.
His joke flopped.
It's ok.
Snake is truly in his flop era in this game.
It's so sad.
Yay, we got Campbell.
Uh...
We didn't see that one.
Inori no Uta.
Oh, we got the other.
We got the Two Hand Princess.
Spoilers.
We got the spoilers.
Ok.
I guess you can't get Sunny then.
That's interesting.
Alright.
Oh, not new game.
Are we ready to continue from where we last saved?
And... Act 2.
What is under extras?
I'm just curious because I don't know if I've ever opened this menu.
Oh, I gotta connect to the network.
I don't think my PlayStation is hooked up to... Hold on, let me see.
It's not.
But maybe next time we can see.
Okie dokie.
Alright.
Load game.
And... Yeah.
I don't know if even the servers are still on, but worth trying, I guess.
Do PS3s even support online anymore?
They do, yeah.
They do.
They did.
I mean, yeah, I played Peace Walker on here.
But I know that they just recently shut down the store, so...
I grabbed, like, all the LittleBigPlanet stuff.
Having a sleepy Sunday, so I might take a nap under this box and just listen to stream.
Have a nice nap.
If Peace Walker doesn't work on PlayStation, there's actually an alternative.
Because you can... The PlayStation one is... You know, you have to own it.
You have to already have it to be able to play it, but...
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky...
Machi!
Happy early Metal Gear.
Happy birthday?
Of course!
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Resalutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you, Machi the Rock!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the Minky.
Yeah!
What was I going to say?
So, for Peace Walker, it's harder to play online with PlayStation because it's harder... It's more difficult to get the game.
But, the Xbox version, you can still buy Peace Walker on the Xbox.
So, I think this time I might actually play the Xbox version because then I feel more people would be able to join in and play together.
I don't know if you can cross play.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
So, we'll do Xbox.
We'll do Xbox this time.
Solid Sun.
Lucky Ducky.
So, I think it's this area right here.
It's where you have to do the farming.
So, I guess I can maybe do a little bit of it or something.
I'm not sure.
We'll see.
We'll see how well I do.
Look how cute that is.
It's a guinea pig.
I wonder how it tastes.
Oh no.
Wait.
Someone's going to figure out how it tastes.
Oh my God.
Oh God.
Here we go.
We're going to see the cheeks baby.
I see.
Somehow making something unique for every gameplay you replay.
I appreciate that.
I want to just not have the same...
Solidus.
We can keep going.
Get more DP.
I feel that ruins the bit rate though.
Holy mountains.
Mountains.
Is this necessary?
Is this... Is this necessary?
Yes.
And no matter who wins, the world has no future.
Until we stop Liquid and destroy the system, we'll never be free.
Snake, what we call peace is an equilibrium kept in check by the war economy.
Destroying the system means wiping out the information society, the end of modern civilization.
Like it or not, we may have no choice but to protract the system.
Oh God.
Snake, here's what we know about the current battle.
Rebel guerrilla units are advancing on the base of the government PMC troops.
That base appears to be Liquid's safehouse.
According to Naomi's data, she's being held here inside the compound.
That's where she is.
Assuming the data is correct.
H-Worm crawling method really works for keeping quiet.
The camera is saying let's prove that Kojima cares about his fans.
My friends!
I'll rescue them.
Don't worry, they'll live.
Yes, got it.
They're green.
They're my friends.
Green people, unite!
Green people!
This!
The worst guy!
This part is so freaky.
That's weird.
But why is he called Vamp?
Vamp.
Vamp having his real bi-panic right here.
Laughing octopus.
She's just appealing to him the most.
Oh?
No!
I don't have as big of boobs as you!
I'm already here, baby.
Vamp.
Oh gosh, why do you...
We're so sneaky.
He smells me.
I think Snake the Light on your...
The solid eye is really not helping.
I'm not so sure they were looking at the face.
That's how I feel.
Beast.
She's a beauty and a beast.
Beauty and a beast.
Yeah, I think we should turn that off.
Tell Otacon to fix that.
Laughing.
The face of the man that killed your sister.
This guy is a pain in my butt.
Yeah!
Right, I know.
Oh, Mei Ling.
North.
Thank you.
Remember these boobas?
They are the boobas that killed your girlfriend.
Let's go, Mei Ling.
Chick booba.
She's amazing.
Laughing.
Snake, yeah.
You're in Snake.
Doesn't matter what age you are.
I mean, what?
Mei Ling was 16 during Shadow Moses, so...
Mei Ling gives me too many toys.
We have to go and find the Missouri.
Just like Mei Ling.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure she was 16.
Man.
The freak I just saw.
It's me!
I got mentioned!
I'm in the game!
Laughing.
Oh?
Sorry, I guess I should have told you.
Stay sharp.
16 to 19.
Now here is where...
We...
We are supposed to farm.
The issue is...
I'm just not quite sure.
I'm pretty sure it's here.
I'm sorry, guys.
I should have done more research.
They're just laying there!
Okay, I'm gonna try and save them.
Let's try and get our friends.
I should have probably... Okay, hold on.
I have to... Oh, I can't see anything.
Never mind.
Do you think if I...
No, you're down.
You're down!
No!
My friends!
Are they still alive?
Is that my friend?
Are you my friend?
No.
I think I killed them.
Oh, shoot.
Good night.
Goodbye.
My friends!
Are they all dead?
Oh, man.
I'm sorry, friends.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean for this to happen.
I tried to save you.
I tried to put them to sleep.
Oh, my friends are dead.
I didn't let them die.
I mean, I tried.
I mean, they did die by my hand.
Oh, no.
They didn't die...
There's someone else.
The whole camp is asleep.
Can I take your weapon?
No, I can't.
They tried leaving.
I'm the worst!
What the hell?
How is this under here?
Hello?
Oh, I can't see anything.
I think there's one more guy over here or something.
What am I seeing on the map?
But he's not moving.
You should be on this boat.
There's snoring everywhere.
It's so funny.
Oh, that's good.
It's a good thing I...
Okay, I'm just gonna go...
Maybe?
What am I... Sorry, snake.
What is moving?
Is it a guy?
Sorry, I think the chat is kind of covering it up.
Let's go investigate.
The camera is not so great.
There we go.
What?
What am I seeing here?
I'm right on top of it.
Oh, there he is!
There he is.
Cute.
I owe thousands of taxes but we bought any Caesar 61.
No, Jonathan!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, but no!
I can't see anything.
Hold on.
Night vision!
Can I get up here?
I saw that there was something up there.
How do I get up?
Jump up?
Nope.
Jump up.
Never mind.
I give up.
I can't see anything worse with this.
We need to go this way.
I'm running.
Thank you so much for the Akasupa, Jonathan!
I need Caesar 61.
I guess we'll just go.
Maybe this is not the location that I thought it was.
Maybe I am a fool.
Come on!
Snake!
Grab it!
Use your arms!
Holy moly, there is a guy right there.
Holy sh...
What?
Oh.
Nothing?
Nothing.
Where are you?
Who is what?
Who is me?
Me?
Oh my gosh.
Gosh, you scared me!
The guy is totally seeing things.
Crazy.
Hold on.
I got to use it.
Crazy.
Oh my gosh, it's Sunday so everything is 20% off.
I forgot.
I think Sunday and Wednesday is right.
Let's go.
Wait.
Hold on.
Trebin Shop.
How much is it?
The expensive...
Oh.
So guys, what we are trying to save up for is...
Oh, it's only 4 million today!
It's only 4 million today!
We could get it.
We can do this.
4 million is actually a lot better than 5 million.
Yeah.
Can I get up here?
Can I now get up here?
There you go snake.
We want the bomb.
Oh my god!
Let's just save.
I hear more people.
Why are there so many people all of a sudden?
Where did they come from?
Who is firing?
Are those my friends?
My friends?
Are here?
Probably?
Where?
Where is everybody?
There is so much action happening around me and I don't know where...
Oh here they are.
My bad.
Oh that's a bad guy.
Oh shoot.
Dang it.
You're welcome.
Are my friends still alive?
Oh shoot.
Ah!
What?
You!
Literally you!
No HQ!
Oh my god.
You had a whole army attacking and now you are going to send reinforcements.
Are you a friend?
It looks like it's green.
Are you not a friend?
Why are you green if you are a friend?
Sleep.
The red name is hostile.
Nevermind.
Don't wake up.
Oh shoot.
The leaf?
Oh no.
Oh no!
We are in a loop!
We are in a triangle loop!
Oh no!
I can do this.
Get the ammo.
Get the ammo?
Get the ammo, Snake.
Snake, get the ammo.
Why can't I get the ammo?
Get the ammo, Snake.
Snake?
Oh I'm full.
Now it tells me.
Okay.
Gosh, I love grass view.
Don't you guys love it too?
The caution will go away eventually.
But they shot after all those people.
And now suddenly they are like...
Now declare caution.
I can't see anything.
Now I can see a little bit.
Come in!
The triangle loop is basically juggling for the viewers.
I can't see anything.
Okay Snake, get out of here.
I still can't see anything.
Okay, there is that guy.
Hey buddy.
Nice.
We are
just going to be...
Snake, you are just going to have to get over your old man-ness.
I'm sorry.
Who just woke up?
Hello, where are you?
Sleepy?
His snoring is so loud.
Get up.
Go, Snake.
And go.
Nice.
I'm full.
Can I...
Climb here?
I think if I...
No, okay.
That's fine.
This is okay.
Everything is fine-ish.
Oh my God.
It's like the tiniest little hole ever.
Damn it!
The bushes gave me away.
How do I get up here?
Laughing Snake.
Who is laughing here?
Nobody is laughing.
Nobody is laughing here.
Oh my God.
Oh my gosh!
My friends!
Question mark?
Do you think they will come down here?
There is a whole lot of people walking around.
Hello.
No.
Maybe?
How do I jump?
Snake sometimes just doesn't want to use his arms.
He is too used to being a T-Rex.
Look at them.
Look at them wander.
They don't even know I'm here.
They don't even know.
Snake, I'm gonna need you to like lift up though.
For real.
And goodbye.
Understood.
The state of alert has been lifted.
Resume position.
Bye!
This guy though.
Is he gonna come over here?
Please don't see me.
My camera is at 75%.
Maybe he turned around.
Turn around.
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
Can I get you?
I think he comes over here, right?
Come here.
Yeah, you get him.
Ok, we are back in the loop.
But like, I think this is manageable.
Right?
Ok, he's really taking the long way.
Don't get him up.
Nice.
Wait, did he kick him up?
Ok.
Snake, go up.
Snake, use your arms.
Snake.
No, Snake.
Snake, use your arms.
Snake.
Snake, lift.
Lift.
There we go.
Ok, buddy.
Good job.
Ok, lift.
Ok.
Oh, there is another guy up there.
I think I got him.
No, I don't trust the grass.
Oh my god.
That was close.
There we go.
Lift.
No, lift.
Ok.
We're...
Is there stairs or something for my old man?
Please.
Snake, lift up.
No.
Lift.
Snake, you can't touch that.
It's barbed wire.
Snake, we are trapped.
This is... This is here.
No.
He needs an escalator.
True.
Snake.
Wait.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
I'm a genius.
Good job.
Up here.
And up.
Good job, Snake.
Good job.
Where is your weapon?
Game is over.
Lift.
No, not here.
Over here.
He needs the tiniest steps everybody.
Please understand.
Do you have a weapon?
You don't even have anything.
Why was I... Why am I worried about you?
He is so old.
How much did I miss?
Not really anything at all.
Oh God.
Oh good.
Psychological counselor.
Clearly they are a good person then.
Oh she.
She.
Hello Rosemary.
She used to work as a data analyst at the Pentagon.
Even he says Jack.
Excuse me?
Call him by his name.
But he wants to be called Raiden.
147.79 147.79
He looks like he is in Psycho Mantis' room.
Couldn't you have found a better time to tell me about this?
Dun dun!
He's like who?
Jack?
I couldn't even...
That's so sassy.
Oh!
Roy Campbell you...
Oof.
Yeah Roy's psychic gauge is going down.
Campbell is a freak.
I hate this.
So bad.
Oh.
Happy birthday.
I'll sing you happy birthday after this.
A criminal.
What a mess.
Holy moly.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Jack Barfoot.
Happy birthday!
Thanks for the superchat.
Look at all the little guys.
My friends!
My friends, my friends.
We are here.
I'm here with you.
Hello friend.
Hello.
Oh sorry.
Hi!
Hello friends.
It's me again.
Oh sorry.
Hello.
I'll help you.
I won't let you die.
I'm gonna help you.
Oh shoot.
Shoot.
Where is he coming from?
Oh shoot.
No!
Yeah I'm good.
I saved you.
You're welcome.
Where?
You need backup?
Hold on.
Let me get my money.
Oh shoot.
I got his ass.
I got his butt.
I got him.
Get me at him.
Oh more?
More of them?
Uh oh.
Ouch!
I thought they were gonna spot me.
I was worried for a second.
Where are you?
There you are.
Oh I just realized my...
shoot.
Get over.
There you go.
There we go.
Nice.
Reload.
My friends!
Everybody is asleep.
Nice.
Where is my friend?
They all lived right?
Nobody died?
Everybody is alive?
Everybody is good?
I got a new gun.
I saw something over here.
I thought...
Friends!
There they are.
There is my friends.
They are covering me?
I'm covering them.
Are there only two of us left?
Sorry.
I don't mean to intrude.
Oh god.
Baddy.
Bad man.
I got him.
Don't worry.
The music was so scary for two seconds.
What's in here?
More ammo.
I think we are okay.
It was like a horror game for two seconds.
It's kind of funny.
My camo is not very good.
Is that my friend here?
No, that is not my friend.
Shit!
God!
Shut up!
Please!
I think I saw a guy over there.
Nope, that's a flower.
That's my friend!
Hey friend!
Is it only just you left?
No.
There was one other guy.
What happened to him?
Uh oh.
I don't think you should go by yourself buddy.
I'm coming with you.
Singular friend.
Friend!
Will you ever attempt a no kill, no alert run of any of the MGS games?
I honestly...
don't have any intentions because...
To me, I don't care about the stealth.
The only real game that I like the gameplay of is Five.
So it's kind of more like I love Metal Gear Story, but the gameplay for me is just kind of like...
not anything that I truly am like...
wanting to master if you get what I mean.
Who is breathing in my ear?
Oh my god.
I'm at your side.
I know that nerdy nerd voice anywhere.
Hello friends.
I'm gonna be helping you guys too.
No!
It's an ambush!
Don't do it!
Don't do it.
It's an ambush.
Don't go!
OK.
Don't listen to Minto.
Hello friend.
Oh my god.
Where are they coming from?
I see him.
OK.
Sorry friends.
You are maybe on your own this time.
Hello?
I couldn't even see where he was.
They won't see me in the grass.
My stress is high.
Oh my god.
Friend!
I'm sorry.
I'll sell your goods and make good profit.
I won't let your money go to vain.
What?
Who saw me?
Where?
Who the hell saw me?
No way.
They were talking about me, right?
That's a little high.
My stress is climbing.
I need the hot... I mean hot lady.
I need to speak to a hot woman.
Oh my god.
There is a lot of bloodshed here.
I'm backing you up.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Is this a good place for...
For tranquilizer?
I can't see if you do that.
I'm backing you up.
I'm out of ammo!
I need to buy more stuff.
Wait, what gun am I using?
Mark 2 pistol.
I'm out of ammo.
Is there an ammo... Bullets.
Oh wait.
Do these work?
These do work.
We can make them cry.
They are a little expensive though.
But it might be cool to use.
Let's try it.
Make them cry.
Make them... Oh no.
Oh my goodness.
Imagine if I just wasted all my money.
Let's try it.
Oh yeah, I do have a sniper.
Actually, did I put it in my... I did not.
Hold on.
I do have a...
Get rid of...
You.
Where is our... Not handgun.
Here we go.
Yeah, put you in.
Thanks.
Is this the Krusty Krab?
No, this is Raiden.
There is nobody else here.
Who are you shooting at?
Oh, they just come walking on in.
I'm backing you up.
You're welcome.
I still feel like this would do some big damage, you know?
The music is kind of awesome.
Take their money.
Hold on.
I got you.
I didn't really, but...
No, they are charging.
Oh, there is a guy up there.
They are
coming in.
Maybe.
I'm gonna grab their money.
We are getting a place.
Aren't we?
There are so many asleep men.
I wonder...
Where is he?
Oh, damn.
That would have been good.
Are you kidding me?
Hold on!
These are all the enemy.
Are they not?
I just got that guy's leg.
Everybody is the enemy.
I'm not the only enemy.
I'm not the only enemy here.
Oh my gosh.
I got you.
Maybe I should be killing these guys.
Oh my God.
I can't see anything.
Oh, he's down.
No, I'm getting everywhere.
I'm getting their money.
OK.
Grab their money.
Who else's money is around?
Hello.
I'm backing you up.
I'm behind you.
I see more money over here.
Oh, it's rations.
My stress is a little high.
You OK, Snake?
Oh, I have full rations.
Let's go.
Back me up.
I got you.
Sniper Legend!
Did I get him?
Minky!
I don't have any...Oh, I do have Pizazz's Ammo, but I just...
You're welcome!
Gold mine!
Oh my gosh.
Is this what they meant by...Oh, I can't see anything.
No, stop moving!
Stop moving!
Hold on.
There's a treasure trove.
Nice.
Charge!
Baby!
I'm just taking...I wish I could take the money.
Damn!
Holy moly!
I don't think I need this anymore.
I'm fighting with my friends!
We're doing a good thing!
Oh, I know what...Oh, that's right.
I have no more...
Wait, should I not have...Let's hold on.
Press the O button to change the type of ammo.
Oh, cry!
There we go.
Alright, time to cry!
Just kidding.
Cry!
It's because my hand is so unsteady because of my...
Because of my stress level.
OK, I guess I'll leave.
Bye friends!
Good luck!
Oh my god, they're so noisy!
They're so noisy!
What the...Hold on.
Oh gosh.
Sorry.
I had a phone call.
Psych!
You don't know where to go?
I'm working on it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Wait, are those my friends or...
Oh yeah, they're my friends.
Holy shoot!
Don't make them cry.
Don't worry about me, friends!
I'm a friend!
I don't think there's any other...I can't tell actually.
I honestly can't tell who's baddie and who's good.
I can't tell who's my buddies!
Get in your box.
Oh I could!
Can I get in here?
Anybody in here actually?
Hello?
Oh my god.
Oh gosh!
That scared the hell out of me!
I'm leaving.
Bye bye!
I'm just a ghost maid!
Keep me out of this!
You think they'll see me?
Where are they anyway?
Oh there they are!
That was so close!
Not me!
You don't see me!
Oh my gosh, my hand is so unsteady.
But you're okay, Snake!
Baby!
Little baby.
He's on all fours crying!
Where did that other guy go?
Oh damn!
They killed him!
I didn't do that.
Oh shoot.
Damn it!
These were expensive.
There you go.
No!
Missile launcher!
How do I get in there?
You alright, Snake?
Let's talk to a sexy lady.
Oh shoot.
Guys, what was Rose's...
There's a baddie in the bottom right corner.
Oh wait, I was winking but you couldn't tell.
What's her codec again?
Oh there it is!
Just kidding.
Rosemary!
You just said that.
Moonya!
Moonya.
I don't think...my controller is 6 axis.
Sorry.
Time to blow what what?
Wait, wait, wait!
Can I get everything inside first?
What do you mean?
Destroy the facility.
What do you mean by that?
Wait, can I get this?
Oh my rations are full.
Grenade!
I can't see!
That was close.
You guys, I'm right here!
Wait!
No, my friend!
Hello!
Excuse me!
I'm right here!
Oh my god!
Please be careful!
Oh, sorry friend!
Sorry!
He doesn't like me very much.
Maybe we can go around.
Oh, sorry Snake.
He got really dizzy from that.
Are you OK?
Oh my god Snake, I'm so sorry.
I just did a victory!
I did a victory roll and he couldn't handle it.
We're fine.
Maybe it will work.
If I can do that...I don't know.
Yeah, I know you can shake it to make her boobs move.
Peak gaming.
Damn it monkey!
No, you shouldn't be smoking monkey!
Who taught you that?
Actually...eat that Snake.
I have you.
No,
we just won actually.
We're so good at this.
No smoking on board!
Our addict monkey.
He's addicted to caffeine and cigarettes.
Little monkey chair.
Especially in the CIA.
Monkey is just like me.
Chill, chill monkey.
What's going on?
We're trying to be secretive here.
It doesn't help if your door is wide open.
Oh boy.
Oh, sorry.
Where are they?
Beauty and the Beast baby!
Why do you say it like that?
Why do you say it like that Snake?
A lady on the field.
Psyche go down.
We didn't have anymore to go down.
Our stress is...
Our psyche is so low that we didn't even have...
You can't hurt me anymore than I've already been.
He just accepts it.
You can't hurt me Dribbin.
I hate myself the most.
War transforms a snake...
Into beasts.
They're tragic backstories.
Dribbin Wikipedia over here.
War transforms us.
But deep within that shell, something human survives.
A fragile and solid heart.
Without a shell to protect it, it's like the yolk of an egg.
Word going round is that natural flesh and blood bodies can't survive in the open for more than a few minutes.
And they've been convinced that by killing Snake, their minds will be cleansed.
They think it's going to free them from all the pain and all the fury.
And what did Snake do?
Cool.
Maybe... Obsessed... With killing me this time?
Crying wolf.
Screaming Mantis.
I can never remember her name.
It's the alien picture.
Oh my gosh!
Octopus Mansion.
We got all the flashbacks.
He can say it!
What?
They are the war economy.
A life of its own.
The system.
Oh!
It works just like natural law.
The world's a much simpler place than most folks realize.
Every aspect of the Patriot system is closely monitored by three peripheral AIs and a core AI that ties them all together.
The SOP system is one part of that.
It's all backed up by a foolproof control system.
So not even yours truly can sneak inside the Patriot's AI.
Well luckily I'm super sneaky.
Or an outer haven.
Wow.
Random guys.
Where?
Yeah, but what if I trick them?
With a box.
It's not me.
It's everybody after me.
Sneaky okay?
Do you need some nanya?
Okay.
Yeah, actually I'm out of ammo.
He blew kisses at me!
Oh, nevermind.
He wants a cigarette.
I thought he was being like...
At me!
I have you!
Bye Trevon!
Bye bye.
Damn, he's fast.
He just scattled out of there.
I have you.
I think the monkey might be Snake's best friend.
That's...
Okay, these are our friends.
We took over!
Look at us everybody!
Our stress is going up?
Why?
Why is it going up?
Snake, chill.
We're safe here now.
It's cool now.
Are these guys all... These guys are all dead probably.
Alright Snake?
What am I hearing whistling?
Snake, are you okay?
I'm running this guy literally ragged.
You're okay, probably.
I think I went the wrong way.
I can't tell.
Let's go in here.
I can't tell if there's guys around here or not.
Where's my friends?
I hear people walking.
They have to be my friends, right?
We took over.
You're okay, Snake?
Just hold out.
You got this.
I hear someone walking.
It's a friend, right?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it's me.
See ya.
Alright.
Okay, we found our way in.
Wait.
Right?
Snake, you're okay.
You're okay, buddy.
How do I get into the other side?
How do I get in here?
In there.
Let Snake eat.
What do you want, Snake?
You want some noodles?
A bit of psyche.
It warms the body.
I need the nunya.
Hold on.
I have...
What?
Sorry, the munya.
Here we go.
Alright.
Yeah, there we go.
Nunya beeswax.
Exactly.
I can't figure out how to get in there.
Unless I'm supposed to blow up the wall.
Oh, I got some sleep gas.
Fun.
We like that.
Let's go.
Hello, excuse me.
I'm friend.
It's me.
Kiss.
Okay.
Rude ass.
Snake.
Stop slouching.
Your gamer pose.
I feel like I have to blow that up or something.
To get in there.
You know?
I feel like I have to or something.
Let's try it.
Oh my gosh, the compress.
Do I still have some?
Let's see.
Oh Snake, you are so high maintenance now.
A syringe.
We have stuff for his hair.
Wait.
Does that help?
Oh, there is a compress.
I have five of them.
Let's go.
Let's switch out the box.
Okay.
Did that help you, buddy?
Oh, my bad.
I went the wrong way.
Okay.
And let's... there we go.
The moon-ya.
Moon-ya.
I'm gonna moon-ya.
Alright, let's try blowing this up.
My sister once got suspended from school because she mooned her teacher.
Let's switch out...
We'll just switch out this for now.
And then we'll do...
We have...
C4.
I only have three though.
I only have three.
L1, plant...
Oh wait.
Ready with L1, plant with R1.
Is this one right?
Okay.
L1, R1.
And then run away.
Run, run, run, run.
Far, far, far, far, far.
And... kapow!
Oh sorry, it was me!
How do you get in there?
The ladder?
There's no ladder on this.
Ladder?
This one?
Is there someone up here?
Just me.
I think.
Oh, and a friend.
How the heck am I supposed to...
Oh, no.
How the heck?
Sorry, I just want to get the missile launcher.
If I hang though...
If I hang...
Oh my god.
It worked.
Great.
Let's go snake.
Falling in slow motion.
We got a rifle scope!
And... some other stuff.
Nice.
And then there's more down here.
This...
The FIM!
How much... did I get any money for that?
Okay, we don't need that.
No money?
Hmm, curious.
Alright, old snake.
Wait, can I do this?
Go up, and then...
And then...
Yeah, and then... there we go.
Easy.
Nice hallminky.
Thank you.
And our psyche is all full.
And we can return...
Our battery is full.
We can leave.
Keep heading north.
What's this?
Oh, C4!
Oh my god.
You...
I can't see.
I can't see...
Oh, there I go.
They really kinda baited me.
I really would've seen that and been like, Oh yeah, I need the C4!
For everything.
I think we probably looted this place enough, so we can continue onwards.
Onwards towards Naomi.
Wait, what's over here?
Versus over there.
Mmm, secret path.
Noodles.
It's me.
Say hi or anything.
Rude.
We got more playboy.
Hello.
Hello, friends.
This is why it's so much more worth keeping the friends, you know?
What is that?
It looks so strange.
Looks like a whale.
Okay.
All my homies hate Naomi.
I know!
You're in good company here.
Anything up here?
No?
Just a little vantage point?
Okay, sorry.
I'm exploring.
Let's go, Snake!
I saved your ass earlier!
And you're gonna be so rude to me?
Scares me.
Yeah, we might be the most anti-Naomi place on the internet.
But you know...
It's all in good fun.
Gosh, look at that.
Hold on.
Let's get him a little less brown.
His cheeks...
Does Snake not feel like the sneaking suit going all the way up his butt?
Who's going?
Me?
I'm going.
If bad, why hot?
That's the best part.
Possibly.
He does, he just likes it.
I've tried wearing thongs before.
And they're just...
I just can't...
It's just always feels like a perpetual...
A perpetual...
What's the thing called?
A wedgie.
Yeah.
Do you think on off days he wears those yoga pants?
Snake,
can you hear me?
This is Jack.
Jack is back.
I read it.
Where are you now?
I'm right beside you.
Oh my God.
Where have you been all this time?
What have you been doing?
On a mission.
Finding something.
For someone.
Finding what?
The corpse of Big Boss.
What?
I was asked to do this in exchange for Sunny's location.
Liquid?
No.
The leader of a small resistance group.
Her followers call her Matka Pluku.
Matka Pluku.
Big Mama.
We'll finish this later.
I'll follow your trail and catch up with you.
Wait.
What about Big Boss's body?
It's with her now.
Her?
Big Mama.
What's going on, Snake?
Rose, I just got a call from Raiden.
It sounds like he's close by.
Jack?
Yeah.
Did he seem ok?
Yeah, as far as I can tell from his voice.
Why doesn't it work?
That's great.
Snake, I have a favor to ask.
It does work.
Don't let him know I'm involved in this operation, ok?
Ok.
I think it would be best to just leave him alone for now.
What happened between you and Jack?
After the Big Shell incident, he became unstable.
Memories began to resurface from his childhood when he fought for Solidus in the Liberian Civil War.
And in the midst of all of that, the baby we had together... it hadn't even been born yet.
She's calling the baby an id.
It's messed up.
And when he did, he'd be dead drunk.
Sometimes covered in cuts and bruises.
Roy was worried.
He was Jack's commanding officer.
But Jack just avoided him.
I was all alone.
And Roy was so kind to me.
He's the one who encouraged me to become a counselor.
I know it sounds like I'm making excuses, but I needed to get over it.
To move on with my life.
I'm worried about him, of course, but I'm also afraid of him.
Alright.
I'll keep my mouth shut.
Thank you, Snake.
Oh, Raiden.
Oh.
Our troubled... he's so troubled.
Our little guy.
I can't tell if these are enemies or pals.
Friend or foe?
Foe.
I see two of them.
I see three of them.
Where are our friends, anyway?
Where are our friends?
Oh, shoot.
Cry.
Oh, are you gonna cry about it?
Are you gonna cry about it?
Do I have to get a headshot?
Does this last?
They sound absolutely distressed.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I just realized.
What the?
Wait, they're crying!
Oh, that's not good.
That's not good.
That's not great.
That's an enemy gunship.
Oh my god!
That's an enemy... get down, boss.
Get down.
That's an enemy gunship.
Come on!
What did I... Oh, just take out the C4.
Boss, get down.
That's an enemy gunship.
We can use the railgun.
We can really take them down with that, probably.
Oh gosh!
Oh, no.
Who's behind me?
You hit.
Let's see.
Where did that guy go?
Oh my gosh, I'm not gonna be able to see anything if you keep blowing everything up!
Yeah, you're welcome.
I'm good as hell.
Sorry, man.
Maybe don't stand in the open, you know?
Where did he go?
I'm taking your money.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Now I'm in the middle.
I'm getting in the middle of it.
You're welcome.
Oh my god.
I'm not killing them, I promise.
It's everybody else.
Very nice.
That's what they say when they see my behind, baby.
Nice, OK.
They blew it up!
What about the helicopter?
What are we gonna do about that?
I'll also... Oh, just kidding.
There's more guys coming in.
Very nice.
Yeah!
Get him!
I'll
take the money and go.
Oh shoot!
No we don't!
Oh my gosh.
Why would you not send reinforcements before?
Why would you not send them before this?
Where are your priorities?
Why am I the problem and not the guys that are literally killing your men?
I forgot that we were on the crying.
I forgot we were still crying.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
I'm a bit of a gamer.
Our stress is getting a little high, but we're OK.
Alright Snake, don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
Oh shoot.
Can I go up here?
Anyone up here?
Oh, there's some ammo.
I'll take it.
He's still crying.
I think.
Cry!
Cry.
I think that's...
We're almost out of...
Just sounds like us before stream.
I know!
I love it!
But I think... Oh wait, we need to go to Dreb and shop.
I think we'll go back to the regular...
The regular ammo.
It's cheaper even.
Let's go with like 5.
I hate spending money.
Are you gonna start crying?
Oh, and then we...
Switch to the...
Anesthesia.
You're welcome!
I wanna take out the helicopter, but can I?
Can I also take out the helicopter?
Wait!
I have big guns!
I have big guns.
We can take him out, probably.
Let's take out the big guns.
Let's see.
Make the helicopter cry?
I just used my last one.
You think we can use the rail gun?
Oops, I didn't put it in.
Let's use the rail gun.
We also got the FIM.
Rail gun!
Where are you?
Anti-tank...
We got the RPG.
Rail gun time!
She loves to see us cry.
Snake, I need you to stand up.
Alright buddy.
Wait, hold on.
I need to go downstairs.
Alright!
We're gearing up for it!
We're gearing up!
That was so exciting!
Stop running!
I'm gonna get you.
Get you!
Yeah!
We did it!
We took him out!
I'm gonna get in the shade a little bit so that our stress goes down.
What are these guys doing over here?
Oh, I think he's dead.
Maybe?
Oh, yeah.
I think they're dead.
Oh, there's more!
I like to help them take out the guys.
It's so fun.
I really need to get their stuff though.
Could they like stop coming out so I could...
Oh, I heard more.
I heard more people guys.
More guys coming out!
Oh, there they are!
Oh,
hold on.
Let me move over just a tad so that you guys can see...
what weapons and stuff I'm using.
Okay!
This is where you farm?
No!
Well, yes and no because...
Not me.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
We got camping.
Because... Oh, shoot.
Wait, they did actually see me.
Where are they?
Is he trying to unload on me?
Oh my god, no!
You've been being attacked!
Why am I the problem?
Oh my god!
I didn't see that guy.
Holy smokes.
I think that hit, but maybe not.
Do you have any stuff I can take?
It's like... I don't think this is the area because...
They said that it was like a place where...
It was a place where you...
Was that at me?
Where is the frog unit?
And they drop like big bugs.
So that's why I'm like, I don't think it's here.
Look at, they're all like burnt to a crisp.
Sounds like Robin.
Sorry, that was supposed to scare me.
Are they coming out?
I think so, yeah.
Oh my goodness!
I can't tell where...
Back me up!
At least we got the helicopter.
It's a lot more quiet.
They're over here too.
Wait!
Oh my gosh.
Is that tank also doing something?
Or am I crazy?
Guy up there, I see him.
Are my friends here?
Is the tank doing anything?
Should I blow it up?
Crazy either way.
Oh, he's still alive.
He made it.
Wow, lucky duck.
Oh hello.
Move, move, move!
We're taking over!
Let me take their weapons.
Please.
Blow it up?
Should we just blow it up for the fun of it?
Yeah, this doesn't even give that much.
Excuse me!
Don't shoot me.
There we go.
And I can go upstairs and get this guy.
I think I can go upstairs.
I can go upstairs somehow.
There we go.
Can you sell the tank?
Gosh, imagine if they introduce the Fulton and everything here so that we could sell tanks and stuff.
It would be big news.
This guy has nothing.
What?
Lame.
Lame, lame, lame.
I like you still love Metal Gear.
Yeah, I do really love Metal Gear still so much.
Run away babies.
Oh nope, those are my friends.
Just kidding.
My bad.
They are my friends.
I wouldn't call them babies ever.
This guy is still asleep.
Nice.
I need backup.
Everybody friends?
Friends and family.
I need backup.
Look, the thing we have... Oh, I didn't even need to shoot him anyway.
No!
You jerk.
They killed him.
I don't have to do anything here.
It's kind of great.
Sneak 100.
They don't give that much I think.
No, my friends!
Back me up.
Fire!
Yeah, you want to take me down?
You have to go through me and this army.
Hello?
Kill him?
You're welcome.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god!
Holy...
You got the tank!
Yeah, I got him.
I got his ass.
They are not going to know where I am.
I got you.
I had you.
I don't have you.
I'm trying to get up the hill.
I'm a little slow.
My old man.
I'm trying.
He's running.
I got him.
I don't have him.
I am good.
Watch my psyche.
We are OK.
We are fine.
Everything is good.
When is this place going to be taken over?
We are farming though.
Where are you?
Where is the enemy?
I'm backing you up.
No!
His weapon disappeared.
I just saw it.
Oh my gosh.
I have to be faster.
Be careful.
Holy cow.
Thank you.
Yeah, I've been here the whole time.
These guys.
Giving Snake a real heart attack?
No!
Our stress is high, but it's just because we are in the daylight.
If I go under here, he will be fine.
It's just like a little worm.
See?
Stress is going down.
Snake isn't used to being out in the open.
He likes to take it more stealthily and chill.
Oh, I can get this guy's legs.
Or not.
Oh, I can.
I can.
He is a bit of an introvert.
Exactly.
Is our stress already halved?
Almost.
Did we win?
I'm going in.
I'm taking the missile launcher.
Charge!
Take all their money.
Don't let them sell anything.
Eventually these guys are going to wake up though, so you might want to actually kill them.
If that's your prerogative, you know.
Oh, friend!
I won't let your money go unpaid.
Our money now.
Who is exploding around here?
Projectile!
I'm going inside.
I'm sneaking in.
Hello, friend.
Oh my gosh!
I'll help.
I would if you let me.
Oh my gosh.
I think that's overkill!
You're welcome.
I won't let your money go in vain.
Go, go, go!
Nice.
Sold that for 3000.
Very nice.
Nice.
Oh, it's chaffing in.
Compressed noodles?
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, they can come in here.
I just thought for some reason it was a blocked off room.
Are you alright, snake?
Oh, our psyche.
No!
Why again?
Snake!
I need some munya.
Munya time.
Gamer posture.
Afraid of natural sunlight?
Snake really is just like you and me for real.
This guy is still asleep.
It's taking a long time to take over this area, huh?
They just don't stop.
Oh shoot.
We're fine.
Everything is good everybody.
Don't worry about it.
It's me.
It's just me, you guys.
Does he have anything to offer with the class?
No?
I don't know, Robin.
What's going on?
Oh no!
This poor sap just woke up.
Oh my god.
They didn't even let him have a second.
Oh my gosh.
I'm here.
Oh, wait.
Is that the guy that just came out?
Yeah!
Poor guy for real.
Oh look, you can see their like... Wow.
That's so cool.
You can see their little octopus.
Damn!
Oh my god, he's already dead.
I'll take it.
Nice, thank you.
Oh gosh!
He's going to come out.
I'm going to get him.
Oh my gosh.
I will.
I got you.
An infinite spawn point.
Actually...
Actually though, kind of.
Charge!
They eventually stop.
1,500.
1,050.
Rodrigo!
Thank you for the 5 gifted!
The guns are disappearing.
I know, I'm trying to grab them when I can.
What's our money at anyway?
We're at 3...31.
300,000.
Yippee!
Only...
That's so painful.
It's kind of slow too.
It's kind of slow here I feel.
It's kind of slow, no?
Oh.
Where the hell did you come from?
Bye?
Rise and shine.
What?
I already took that other guy's stuff.
The rocket launcher against the sleeping guys is kind of insane to me.
Damn!
Oh my god, he was just asleep.
Are any more going to come out of the building?
I am!
Oh, uh oh.
Got
him!
Hold on, I'm going to take his weapon.
That's a big money.
Oh gosh!
Who's shooting me?
Ouch!
Aren't you supposed to be my ally?
They are actually trying to kill me.
You cannot reach him!
You cannot get him unless you come here.
I almost feel like leaving, but...
I feel like this place is kind of slow to farm, you know?
Even if we've been farming a little bit.
I thought that they would take over the building like they did before.
That doesn't seem to be the case.
Oh, damn it.
Not anymore.
It was a trap.
You'll never find me in here!
You'll never catch me alive!
Did he see me?
Is this a bad...
I can't tell.
That's a bad guy, right?
He looked right at me, but...
To me?
Did you just blow yourself up?
Oh no.
OK, just kidding.
That would have been so funny.
Alright, let's go.
Let's move on.
Shit.
Help me!
You're supposed to be my friend!
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
No more.
No, Snake, get underneath.
Snake, go underneath please.
I need you to get some stress down.
Someone just came out.
Where did they go?
Contact where?
Me?
No.
You're a liar.
You're lying.
Let's leave, guys.
Oh, I put my friend to sleep!
Sorry, I thought you were the enemy.
Everybody is my enemy!
OK, let's get our stress down a little bit more.
Oh my god!
There he goes!
We just watched him phase out of existence.
That was crazy.
Are these my friends?
No.
Foe.
You're a foe.
Yeah, we are in a de-stressing environment.
I would like for them to kind of charge again, so I don't get caught, but...
I think we're OK.
We're not OK.
How do I get you?
Did I get him?
I don't know.
Oh, I think I did.
Dum-dum.
Stupid.
Oh look, there's more stuff.
See, there's like some playboy things here.
There's...
Now we're just gonna leave.
Got things in here.
Oh!
New weapons.
We love to see it.
Not me.
Focus on the guys that are actually trying to kill you, I think.
OK.
Let's leave.
That's sold for 12,000!
What was that?
What did you have?
Give it to me.
Give me more.
What else did you have?
Oh!
Big money.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I think he actually left.
Hey!
Bye bye.
I'm a little... I don't wanna... I'm sick of this area.
I'm sick of this area!
It said it was custom parts.
I'm not quite sure.
Oh, my friends.
Hello everybody.
I can get him.
Trust.
It never ends!
This war!
This war never ends!
Oh my gosh!
Just everywhere we go.
Let me get the machine gun.
Does that say it's only 200?
Only 200 money?
3,000 money!
OK, so the number means nothing.
What do you got?
1,000 money?
Money?
He
scared me.
I really have a helmet on, guy.
Sorry guys, I'm so...
I ate that!
Oh my god!
I absolutely ate that!
Snake, are you OK?
Holy moly!
What?
That was intensive.
Gosh!
Snake, the rebels have got an armored dozer.
They're probably going to use it to bust their way into the mansion.
Give it some cover and it might get you inside the compound.
I got him.
I'm taking him out.
That was so easy.
Charge!
Is there still money available?
Or we're just all inside now?
Sorry, my focus is all... I'm so money motivated.
I'm too money motivated, guys.
I need to change my ways.
But I mean...
With all this sweet, sweet cash everywhere.
You're still alive?
Or...
No, I think you just got rolled over.
Oh, that's a friend coming up.
Oh my gosh, you scared me.
Back you up?
Or...
We do?
Oh, Naomi.
I thought he said back that up.
Back me up?
I completely heard the wrong thing.
There's the launcher.
Oh, I see him up there.
I got you.
Backing you up, buddy.
Oh my goodness.
I'm charging.
I'm charging my bank account.
The music is so cool here though.
Can I get that guy?
I think that hit.
Ration.
I'll take that.
What's over here?
I bought music.
Wait, where?
Sailor.
Healing music that can be heard by calling a secret radio frequency in the game.
I got you.
I'm backing that up.
I think I'm getting this guy.
Oh wait, that's my friend.
Sorry.
Guys?
I'm one of the baddies now.
But I've always been a baddie.
Oh, these are my friends.
Cool.
I'm helping?
Maybe.
Maybe?
Cover!
Oh my gosh, please.
Can I please hit a guy?
Please can I shoot a man?
Yeah, baby!
Yeah, I did.
You're welcome.
Back that up.
There's a guy right there.
How do I get him?
Seriously?
Ass saved.
You are welcome.
Grenade!
I can't tell if some of these guys are the ones that I put to sleep and they just didn't...
They just didn't...
Oh my goodness!
Can I get yourself?
Alright, I'm off to find a lady friend.
You guys, good luck with everything else.
Good luck with everything else.
I will see you around.
Probably.
She's a friend.
Friend is definitely a strong word, you know, obviously, but...
She's over in here.
Don't quite remember how to get there.
Hey, snake.
Hi, snake.
Over where?
Under...
Under where?
Oh gosh!
Catching strays.
From where?
Oh my goodness, there they are.
Guys, do you remember?
Do you remember?
Is it inside?
I thought she was in a different building.
Like she's in her own little, like, shed.
Uh oh, my friends are dying.
Damn.
Missed the gun.
It's a hole, you go inside.
Thank you, I can't remember.
Back me up.
Yeah?
Hello?
Hey, hello.
Oh gosh, no!
Shoot!
Oh gosh.
Go inside, snake.
Let me see.
We're fine for now.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Hold on, let me get my... I got a knife too.
I got one also.
Yeah!
Stab!
Stab him!
That works.
Whatever.
What's this?
Got a ration.
Cool.
We're running.
I'm making a mess.
Anybody up here?
No one?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, what's this?
Sorry, I keep missing stuff.
Oh, I'm full.
Let's try...
Doing that.
I think we got it.
Claymore.
Good luck everybody else, good luck friends.
I believe in you all, I believe in you.
I think you can do it.
lol Why not clay less?
Who would want to clay less?
Truly.
Nice.
Snake's ass is great in this game.
It's literally the best it's ever been.
I think.
It's the best that it's ever been.
Oh, I was sweaty.
You okay, Snake?
My golly!
They won't let you leave, Naomi.
Oh gosh.
Just hearing her voice...
It's ruining my time.
Not a fan of Naomi?
No.
You could even say less... Oh my gosh, this hallway.
I remember it.
I remember this building well.
Isn't there a secret L1 here?
I think I remember.
I'm just holding it down.
She got the IVS happening.
You need a little...the prick?
Aren't you cold, lady?
I knew you'd come.
You and I, neither of us can escape our fate.
I haven't seen you since Shadow Moses.
How long?
Ten years?
Nine.
Nine years.
And Dr. Emmerich, is he with you?
Why?
I thought he'd be the only one able to open the mail I sent.
Not many people could recognize 4D sound data in a soliton radar file.
How is the good doctor?
What happened to your accent, you fake?
You are so fake, everything.
Who were you just talking to?
Liquid.
Although I suppose he's really Ocelot.
From a medical standpoint.
I thought he was here.
Did you see her?
Did you see it?
They know I won't escape.
I'm powerless to resist.
I have no choice but to cooperate.
She's kind of got an accent.
Oh, I'm powerless.
It's like barely.
Barely.
I did not remember this building.
Ah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Mail?
I'm sorry, I'm blocking her.
The fan service.
Sorry, everybody.
I'm scared.
That's true.
I give the people what they want.
Oh, that's such a big needle.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Snake ain't looking so hot.
Snake is looking not so good.
He's looking mighty pale.
Hmm.
Hormones.
Yeah, I'm playing on my PS3.
Okay.
Crazy.
Ooh, Naomi.
This is a bad picture of you.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Okay, her password is... how many...
How many digits was that, like 12?
I think we can figure that out.
I think we can get in there.
Oh.
Password is tight, but...
She can't stop thinking about Snake.
Hmm.
What's that emotion?
What is that one on the right?
He looks so... smoked?
The fear.
That's the fear?
Fear?
Gray Fox?
So cool.
Oh my god.
Art is so good.
My bit rate!
Those are all the games we played.
Exciting.
So cool.
Oh man.
Hey Snake.
Never change, Snake.
Never change.
Hmm.
Oh my goodness.
Um...
I mean...
Hmm.
Oh!
Okay, ma'am.
But as long as you, you know...
Treat me well, okay?
Oh, Snake.
I hate this part, though.
I hate her.
It's like your reaction is so crazy.
Snake...
He's just a guy.
She's like going to throw up about him.
She's so rude.
Why are you crying at him?
You can tell he has accelerated aging and then you see his body and you just start sobbing.
It's so sad.
I hope I look that good when I'm old.
I know, right?
Look down.
He looks great.
I mean, I know he's not supposed to be old, but...
For someone who is old, he looks awesome.
It's a granddaddy.
Oh, Snake.
He looks awesome.
Terminator.
Sorry.
Even though it's a guy.
It was a safety device to ensure that the seed of Big Boss didn't end up in the hands of others.
The reason you're aging so rapidly isn't because of disease or faulty research or fox die.
It's how you were born.
It's your natural lifespan.
It's depressing.
I know.
I hate... I love and I hate this game.
It's so sad.
Okay, so we'll do a new save.
Just blame the genes like you always do, Naomi.
So sad.
The truth, Naomi.
Scanning for fellow Naomi heads.
You'll be added to a watch list of monitored men.
Copying Solid Snake.
The question she'll never answer.
At
least let the man have a cigarette.
What?
Whose fault is it that it's there in the first place?
She just loves not taking responsibility for anything.
Sorry, I just hate her so much.
But she's so hot.
She is a looker.
Remember those guys?
God, I hate Naomi.
Also Mint.
It's not me, it's Snake.
What?
The real liquid.
The virus is starting to mutate.
The viruses on the left are Foxtai in its original form.
The ones on the right I took from your body.
He's pregnant.
Snake is a freak, Mint is a freak, he tore a piece of a pod.
This mutated version of Foxtai could activate even if the infected person's genetic pattern doesn't perfectly match the receptors.
It does look like a pair of boobs.
I'm gonna eat some of my sandwich.
I hope it's okay while the cutscene is going.
It'll become a killer virus that attacks untold numbers of victims.
What if we kill them all?
Remove them from the body?
There are no antibodies either.
I don't know what percentage of the receptors have to break down or how many people will be targeted when that happens.
But what is certain is that people will begin to catch Foxtai through airborne transmission.
It'll start with those closest to you.
Then, one by one, they'll lose their lives.
The part of the virus that distinguishes between individuals will start to break down in about half a year.
No.
Wow, it's almost like we...
Three months at the most.
Three months?
It's almost like we should have, you know, not have used this weird experimental... something.
Nuclear annihilation.
Whatever this is, a weapon.
On a random person.
Yeah, and it's your fault, Naomi!
You made this!
Don't blame Snake!
I can't.
Put him in a little bubble.
Jim Hausman's fault.
And Naomi.
Naomi followed through.
She takes all the blame as well.
This game hurts so bad, but I love the pain.
I know, it does hurt bad.
Will that stop FOXDIE from spreading?
No.
When the host dies, the virus dies with it.
You just want an excuse to kill Snake!
Finally, he gets his smoke.
Snake, tell me one more thing.
Have you been to a hospital lately?
Yeah.
While you were there, did they give you an injection?
Don't they always?
Take a look at this.
These came out of your body as well.
Twins.
It's a new strain of FOXDIE.
One I've never seen.
Someone must have put them in you recently.
You have any idea who?
Him.
Ruh-roh.
I like that we just blindly trust her.
Snake just takes everything, huh?
I mean, but who are you supposed to tell who you can believe?
Who you can trust?
Especially in this series.
Give a shot?
Ok, I'll do it.
Oh, shoot me up too?
Ok, I got it.
Ok.
Give me the drugs, Naomi.
I'll trust you lady who gave me a killer virus.
Ok.
I let myself drown in my nanomachines and now I'm trapped by them.
Snake has to take more drugs than my grandpa.
He is a grandpa.
I can't slip free.
Then I'll free us both.
Where's Liquid?
I can't tell you yet.
What?
Not until you free me.
One must come before the other.
To release you, we must do the other.
He's being watched by us.
This is the first Metal Gear you played.
How did you know what was going on?
Uh oh.
Guns of the Patriots.
Gosh, I got something.
I got like a little piece of pepper in my throat.
These are the guys that drop the big bucks.
She's the juggler.
Your Octocamo looked so good before.
Why is it bad now?
It's time.
I can't remember if I have to...
Hold on, I want to take a ration real quick.
Use...
Obviously on Laughing Octopus, I have to use Tranquilizer.
But...
It's time to farm.
Yeah, I think this is where we farm.
For real.
But how?
I don't remember.
Where are they?
Froggies!
Here?
I'm at 83% camo.
Oh.
It
didn't give me as much as I thought it would though.
Oh my gosh.
It didn't give me as much money as I expected it to.
Back it up, back it up.
Like, it gives me 1500.
1500.
But I think they are just non-stop.
There's like an X on my map.
Yeah, it's like not very much at all.
I thought that these were supposed to be the ones that were 12,000.
I wonder if that other area was the one.
Farming is done at the confinement facility.
Was that the last place I was at?
The one that dropped the...
The one that... So, I probably did miss my chance then.
What's the confinement...
Mod, where is that?
Where am
I?
End of game is way better farming.
I know, but this...
Well, yeah, but...
I wanted to get it sooner rather than later.
You know, I wanted to get the good stuff...
Now.
I wanted to get...
Oh man, why 4 million?
Why 5 million?
And...
It has like a watchtower and barbed wire walls.
So, the place I was at...
Okay, we'll figure it out.
Oh shoot.
Can you like...
Hello?
Wake up.
Not, not wake up.
No, that's the opposite of what I want you to do actually.
Where are you?
Come on in.
Whichever way you choose.
Madam?
Got your booty.
Oh, no, that is not all of them.
More definitely just came in.
So yeah, this must be like a...
But you can farm here, because they're like...
They don't...
They don't stop coming and they don't stop coming.
I really thought it was the froggies that were supposed to be the ones that drop the good money.
I'm so upset.
Sorry guys.
I didn't do my research well enough.
They do indeed stop coming.
They do.
Eventually.
I think I missed this one.
Where was the other one?
Oh my gosh, the standing scared me.
This is locked.
Sell for money.
One moment.
Snake!
Oh gosh.
That scared the heck out of me.
That scared me.
I was just gonna head to the point.
Oh my goodness.
I could have sworn I did all the beauties...
Non-lethally.
Or most of them.
I know I did for sure like this lady.
But I don't understand why I don't have her statue.
Maybe I missed picking it up.
The photo mode?
It's like a time limit though, right?
Get the iPod ready.
Language!
Belly button.
It changes my gun.
That's so messed up.
Ah!
That's like no damage.
Wait, hold on.
What other tranq stuff do I have?
Get out of here, operator.
I don't think I... I think besides...
Besides this...
I don't think I have anything.
The shotty has a non-lethal ammo?
Does it really?
Wait, let me see if I have... if I can get it.
Dreb and shop.
Ammo.
They taunt me.
Custom par... Oh, here we go.
This?
This one?
We can do it with the twin barrel, maybe?
Ok.
What else is there?
These ones too.
Nice.
I'm just going to blast her with RPG.
Ok, let's get like...
Can I only...
It will only let me buy...
One round.
Why?
Are you out?
Dreb, is this all you got?
No!
I'm full of ammo.
Oh, wait, hold on.
One moment, lady.
Hold on, I have to switch out my stuff.
We don't need the railgun.
Ok, what are we going to use?
Where is it?
Under...
Oh, here we go.
Twin barrel might be good, right?
I think...
Probably double barrel shotgun.
Ok.
And we switch the ammo on it.
The V-ring.
V-ring.
Vortex ring shot.
Ok.
Ma'am?
I'm scared.
She does like to hide and seek, right?
Gosh!
Oh my god, that scared the heck out of me!
Holy!
We are recovering some health from being here.
Hold on, let me recover health real quick.
She disappeared on my radar.
Ok.
Sorry, I have to remember how to do this fight.
She like goes into hiding, you know?
She is an octopus.
We are recovering health, which is good.
I don't have to use a...
I think I know where you are though.
Did she see me?
Damn it.
I forgot.
Ma'am?
Oh there you are.
What are you doing?
Stop breaking everything!
Oh my god.
Reload!
Did she see me?
Hell yeah!
Reload!
Oh damn!
I got you too!
Reload!
Oh shoot.
Oh shoot, it's these...
Is that her?
Oh, that's awkward.
Uh...
Let's do a...
Ration?
Wait, I want my solidite.
There we go.
Thank you.
Smoky again.
OK!
It's these things, right?
Yeah, yeah.
OK, I hear her over maybe this side.
Where are you?
Something wrong?
Hello?
Give me a hint?
Where?
Where are you?
You sound so close.
I'm blind?
Wait, hold on.
Night vision.
I thought I had like a thermal vision.
Oh my gosh.
Where?
I'm blind.
I'm actually blind.
Where are you?
My eyes?
Yeah, me too.
Hello?
Where are you?
Ma'am, I think I'm blind.
Can I get a hint?
Look up?
Oh my gosh.
Hello?
Again?
Minto gaming?
Not really.
OK.
Hold on, let's do night vision again.
Sorry guys.
My eyes.
Yeah?
What are you doing in there?
Sorry, one second.
Are you on the other side?
Are you clipping through the wall?
How am I supposed to get her out of there?
Oh, I think maybe like here.
What?
Aim lower.
There we go.
Smokey!
Oh my gosh.
You bitch!
Where did she go?
Get on top.
Oh dammit.
Oh,
these things again.
OK.
I heard her.
Oh my gosh.
No!
Don't explode on me!
Snake.
Yes?
Where are you?
Yeah?
This is so...
I'm so bad at this battle.
That's not her.
It's not me.
It is you.
Sorry.
Oh my god!
Scared the hell out of me!
Yeah!
Take that!
Dang it.
It's not the ball.
Not the ball!
A
little bit more left to go, which is great.
No!
You're not... You're not...
Oh my god!
Sorry.
It's so scary.
It's so scary when she just...
And then the music... And then she's laughing.
No, that's not Anika.
Ma'am.
Where are you?
Oh goodness.
What is that sound?
Oh my eyes.
Yeah?
Is that you?
A little bit more.
We're almost there.
Oops.
My bad.
No shit!
Otacon!
She's in the ceilings!
She was.
Wait.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
OK.
We're dancing.
I go one way.
You go the other way.
That's OK.
Works for me.
I think I missed my shot.
Damn it.
Oh my gosh!
Come on!
OK.
No more hiding out?
Bye!
Oh bye!
Oh damn!
Ouchie, ouchie, ouchie.
I still wanted to get the shot.
OK.
We're mostly OK maybe on... Oh my goodness.
On health for now.
Awesome!
We're almost there.
She's gonna probably come through the ceiling again here, right?
Yup.
Oh damn it!
Damn it!
Oh my gosh.
OK.
Ration time.
And reload.
And what is she gonna do?
We got... Oh my gosh.
So close.
Damn it.
Come on lady.
Are you gonna come down through here?
Where are you?
Oh man.
The way she like moonwalks.
Ma'am?
Which way are you coming from?
Oh, there you are.
Oh, never mind.
There you go.
I'll come to you.
You come to me.
What you, what you, what you, what you?
Left or right to push?
Oh, there you are.
And... Oh, never mind.
Fight me!
No.
I like that I can just get on the bed here.
Oh my gosh.
So close.
And she's down.
Again.
And she's back.
Is
it sexy hour?
Time for the two set checkie.
So icky.
Icky.
I love the thing on her head.
It looks so much like, like Ray.
No.
And I'm Minto.
I think she's my favorite of all of them, to be honest.
She's really cute.
Hilarious, even.
Wow!
When you're a deranged babe, but you still got time to do your makeup in the morning.
Got that smokey eye.
Can't stop laughing.
Won't stop laughing.
Oh.
It just pushes her over.
Uh oh, the voices.
I'm scared.
I'm really scared.
Waiting for the twit longer.
We need the sorry I laughed apology.
Sorry.
Uh oh, did it again.
We're gonna have to punish you, girl.
Oh, you don't want to laugh, but you're laughing, girl.
I don't remember how to go into the...
I can't believe I keep switching my gun.
It's kind of messed up.
Yeah.
The statue.
Do I have to get it now?
Oh my goodness.
Hello.
She like avoids my...
Oh, nevermind.
It's the cam.
Oh gosh, I can't remember this mode.
Sorry guys.
Hold on.
Everybody is telling me a bunch of things at once, so I'm kind of like...
I'm a little...
Do I have to bait her or...
Oh dammit.
I'm stuck.
Oh no, she's got me.
Nice angle.
Anyway, women.
Gosh.
Statue first.
Oh, where's the statue?
Wait, no wonder I never got it then.
Wait, no way!
No way.
Wait, I don't get the statue?
Too late!
No, no way.
Seriously?
Okay, you guys...
You can't say we told you when I'm...
When there's like a bajillion messages at once on screen.
People were saying the camera, people are saying the statue, people are saying hold it out.
Like, there's not really a way that I can like...
See everything at once, okay?
So...
That's never a helpful comment.
And honestly, I think that kind of comment would piss anybody off.
Oh...
I don't know what to do.
I have to restart from my last...
You guys, I don't know the last time I saved.
Last save was talking to Naomi.
Oh, you're right.
Okay.
Yeah, we did save talking to Naomi.
We'll just have to do the fight again.
Where is... Does anybody know where the statue is so I can just grab it really easily?
Oh, that's so annoying.
I'm so...
Why is it also... Why can't I get it afterwards either?
Why can't I get it?
Why can't I get it after the... Oh, that's why.
That's why.
On the bed.
Okay.
Got it.
For those who don't realize what the statue is, basically, if you defeat the enemies non-lethally...
Also, she had, like, half health, so that's why I thought I was fine.
She was at, like, half Trank health.
If you defeat the boss babes non-lethally, you can collect a statue of theirs.
And the statue...
If you collect all of them, you get to unlock a special weapon, and I want that weapon.
So, Micmac, thank you for the 10 gift, and thank you.
Alright, let's do this all over again.
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
Gosh dang it.
I'm so frustrated.
You guys were saying the statue, I just didn't realize I was going to kill her so fast.
That's my fault, I guess.
I didn't realize I would get her so easily.
I'm just a gamer, I guess.
Please let me change weapons.
Where are they?
Are they coming this way?
Oh, there they are.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you didn't even notice.
And then we remember, they don't drop very good loot, but that's okay.
This side?
I think they come... Never mind.
They come through over here.
Oh, shoot.
Man!
What does... What do you mean by that?
Hello?
Can you come back?
Oh, shoot.
Gosh, lady.
You scared the heck out of me.
Take.
Okay.
These guys are in here.
Pretty sure.
Oh, woah, woah, woah.
Oh, there's V-Ring ammo right there.
You see that?
I wonder if that will work for me.
Hello?
Froggies?
Frog?
Oh, I missed him.
I missed him.
Frog?
Oh, shoot.
I need to be a little more aggressive, maybe.
Oh.
Oh, frog.
Can you come out?
I'm like super chill right now.
Oh, my gosh.
God, that scared me.
Hello?
We're chill.
Just realizing the reload.
I'm almost out of bullets.
Oh, geez.
Sorry, I'm being a little passive here.
I'm still... I'm still salty.
I'm still salty.
Where'd she go?
Oh, my God.
There we go.
At least the...
At least the... What's it called?
The octopus fight.
It's not bad.
It's just, you know...
Sometimes it's hard to find...
Why?
Yeah, maybe come in here.
Yeah, let's check it out.
Yeah, come on in here.
Or do nothing.
Okay, here they go.
Oh, shoot.
I'm almost out of ammo.
Let me buy some more.
Wait.
Operator.
Oh, this is a suppressor.
I'm stupid.
I was like...
They were... They're all blind, so I...
I was like, wait a second.
These...
Are...
These are shaped.
Did I buy it?
There we go.
Okay.
Ma'am.
Oh, they're both still here.
My bad.
Oh, my gosh.
Nice.
And...
Where's the other one?
Where are you?
Lady?
Oh, oh.
No, I got you!
Please!
Thank you.
Oh, gosh.
CP.
Is that it?
Is that all of them?
Is it time for snake?
I mean octopus.
Octopus time.
I think I have to go into the hallway.
Alright, let's get my gun.
Let's change my gun.
No more real gun.
We do.
Oh, what was it?
Wasn't it an other fighter?
No.
Rifle.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Sorry.
Can you dance with the sad laughing octopus?
I will try.
I think I have to hold out a little bit.
I have to like...
Okay.
There is an X over there.
Snake!
Here she comes!
And we will skip the cutscene.
Snake!
And run!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, no.
Wait!
I need a bed!
Oh, never mind.
Oh, it's these guys.
I thought she was curling into a ball.
Where are you?
Are you in the ceilings?
Like that.
And she's gone.
And she's back.
And she's away.
Dang it.
I wanted a headshot there, but I didn't have a chance to.
Nice.
Okay.
And what about...
Yep.
Oh, never mind.
I think...
Oh, no.
I think her rolling around is next phase.
Ma'am!
Oh, I think I hear her.
Or is that those?
Are you in the ceiling?
I love hide and seek time.
It's kinda chill, actually.
Just you try and find me.
It's falling!
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
I can't see anything.
I'm actually stuck.
Okay.
We're good.
We're chill.
Everything's fine.
Sometimes she's bawling.
Sometimes she's not bawling.
Oh, ration?
Thank you.
Yeah.
Let's use a ration.
Thank you.
Where are you?
Night vision.
Everybody, close your eyes!
She is... that?
This is not her.
What?
This?
The box?
What box?
Or this?
No.
The box?
Oh, shoot the box.
This part.
That's kind of funky.
Finding her again.
Sorry for your eyes.
Sorry for your...
This part is neat.
I do enjoy this part.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's fun to see what she...
She's bawling!
Oh no!
I missed!
I'm eating bullets.
Oh gosh, that was not good.
This stinking... again.
Where are you?
Not a con.
Oh, there...
Dang it.
This way, snake.
What?
You're not some dummy dum-dum?
Oh man!
Wait, what?
What just happened?
Just kidding.
Where is
she?
Alright, sorry for your eyes again.
Is this her?
Yep.
Oh, come on.
Really?
Night vision.
Where is she at?
Me first!
I've always wanted to do that!
You
think I wouldn't think twice?
Ouch, ouch.
Oh god.
Sorry guys.
Shoot.
I should have rationed.
We were so close too.
Sorry, I just wanted to check.
Gamer conservation moment, truly.
I messed up.
I take the blame.
Ma'am, where are you?
Oh gosh, I didn't even see it!
At least it didn't do so much damage.
Octolady, where are you?
Did that hit?
I think it did, but not very much.
It could have been better.
It could have been so much better.
She's so frustrating.
Nice save.
Wait, is this...
No, she's...
She's balling out, but...
Your hatred of Naomi is irrational.
Why are you guys plus twoing that?
Never!
What?
Plus two where?
Yeah?
That's my name!
Don't wear it out!
But...
Oh, just kidding.
Why did it say laughing octopus then?
Am I crazy?
Is this actually her?
I'm confused.
Where the hell is she?
Up in the rafter?
Oh!
Gamers never look up.
Oh my gosh.
Why did it say that's her then?
Poor woman.
She's just really asleep, you know?
Oh my god.
I can't get her...
I can't get over her like slithering through.
It's so funny.
No!
I wonder how speedrunners do this one.
Oh, no!
Wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong.
I was preemptively getting ready for the...
for the ball.
I'm not doing so hot this round.
This way?
Okay.
Night vision!
Go!
Oh, there she is.
She's the box again.
We got her.
Tempting, man.
And then she's gonna crash through, right?
She's crashing out, literally.
Actually, I don't know where she is.
Sorry.
So funny.
I'm right there.
I'm right here.
Oh, reload.
Oh, shoot.
I missed my chance.
Now,
where is she?
Now, where could she be?
Where is she at?
Night vision!
Run!
No, no, no.
Ew.
Oh, my gosh.
Zoom in.
What?
Call Otacon?
Oh, sorry.
I missed it.
Let's see what he says.
I'll call him.
Snake, Octopus's suit seems to work the same way as your Octocamel.
It'll use mimicry and traps as weapons against you.
Stay focused.
Don't be deceived by its disguises.
I'm deceived.
Shoot.
Oh, wait.
She gassed.
Oh, no, no, no.
She went gassed.
I thought she was rolling.
Instead, she's gassing.
Is that you?
Finally!
Naomi!
Does he say anything here?
I've always wanted to do this.
There she goes, slithering on by.
By the way, she moves so awesome.
Oh,
you're going to shoot from up there?
I love the way she's like, no.
Just slithers on.
Yeah, that's what I thought, lady.
Bye-bye.
Damn it.
I'm not going to...
Trying to figure out if I want to ration or not.
Got her.
OK, we're close.
Nice.
One more.
Slide away.
Alright, now we statue.
Just reminding you about the statue.
Find it before you enter the white void world.
I'm going to skip this cutscene since we just saw it.
I'm sorry.
I got it!
Yeah!
Makes a great gift for Sunny.
OK.
Where is she?
She's kind of freaking me out.
I have to wait until...
Oh, damn.
I messed up.
Damn it.
I messed up again.
OK, I'll wait.
I'll wait.
We get all the cool... what's it called?
I missed anyway.
She's so fast.
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
How strong are my bullets?
Sorry guys.
We'll get them next time.
How strong are my bullets?
We'll get the photo shoot next time.
But like, they're not... sometimes it does little damage, sometimes it does big, big damage.
Mission failed.
Truly a mission failed.
No!
This is a fish and mailed moment.
It's OK.
We got other ladies we can dance with.
I'm always scared about that part though, because I'm afraid of not making it in time.
And she becomes a cocoon.
And she's back to baby.
Just a little baby in the womb.
But she's alive, because I did that.
She's just a sleeping baby.
These camera shots, I know, they're quite cultured.
Everybody gets fan service in these games.
It's amazing.
The Octo.
We can become Deadpool.
The eepy baby unit.
It's true.
The baby is still afoot.
What?
OK, Drebin is going to lure a drop real quick, but I really need water.
So I'm going to go grab some water super duper fast while he explains the lure.
But I'm not going to miss all of it, because he just talks forever.
I'm going to run.
BRB
It's not my size or shape.
Yeah, looks like you could use a bit of tailoring before you can sport it.
Not my line of work, but...
Ain't you got a buddy who specializes in that kind of thing?
Somebody's done their homework.
Hey, here's my job.
Is that the real reason you injected me with those nanomachines?
To spy on me?
I prefer the term customer data management myself.
Drebin!
Relax, it's strictly confidential.
I ain't gonna share it with anybody.
Then what did you mix a virus in with the nanomachines for?
Virus?
A certain virus was detected in my body.
Are you saying it wasn't in the nanomachines you injected?
Look, you do know there are other folks who could have done this to you.
And besides, what would I gain from infecting you?
Better for me that you're out there kicking ass on the battlefield.
Did he start the lore?
I was watching you, Snake.
You're a real piece of work.
Never thought I'd meet the man who could take down...
He hasn't even started it?
She just kept on laughing.
Oh here it is.
And what do you suppose that is?
Something to blast.
You got it.
Oh I made it back for the lore.
I even took medicine for my throat.
Perfect timing, truly.
Such a yapper.
Jarbin waited for me, honestly.
Welcome back from the BRB unit.
That's good.
Sleepy fish.
Her eepy baby fishing town.
Oh wait, that sounds kind of bad.
They were not fishing for babies.
Darkwing Dumb, thanks for the 10 gifts.
Aww.
These stories are always like...
What's the worst thing that could happen to a person?
That's what happened, times 10.
Aww.
Just some context.
Right?
Thank you for the hakusupa.
I knew you'd be the only one who knew how to celebrate the year of the snake in style.
You're pretty good here.
Thank you!
Thank you for the hakusupa, mustache man!
Thank you so much.
Okay, now we continue.
At least I got the statue.
I promise, I promise.
For the other babes, we'll dance with them.
We'll have them.
I do have the camera.
Oh no.
Snake.
Snake?
This guy worries me.
Snake, you make me worry too much, buddy.
Oh no.
Wait, no.
Is this where we have to use the vision?
To follow the footsteps?
Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh!
He's checking the size of her feet.
What a freak.
Nice feet.
Okay, she's got them pointy heels.
But then, I remember she changes her socks.
I was thinking, I was misremembering this part in Act 3.
I was like, at least I don't have to do the tracking part today.
Ugh.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean by that with Big Boss?
You are so stupid, Rylan.
Awareness.
Okay.
I'm looking for the bent grass.
Oh, I need the 4D PS3.
What?
That one bird that's just like...
Help!
You learned ninja techniques in Alaska?
You're that ninja.
I like how he's trying to...
He's backseating the master of stealth.
Me.
What?
It actually makes me so mad.
That he's just like, by the way Snake, in case you don't know how to sneak.
Like, shut the hell up.
It actually makes me mad.
Especially that it's riding.
I'll give it a shot.
And blast that guy.
Okay.
Let's see.
Let's switch out.
I'm gonna switch this back to the...
I don't think I'll need it, but just in case.
So you can be as chuny as Raiden.
Raiden got a trip on that edge, it's true.
This guy is so silly.
Take it easy on Jack, he's just had a Kotori moment and explaining some exciting new thing he just learned.
Okay.
Oh Sunny, are you okay?
My SunnyCam, is she alright?
Wait, is that the statue?
Is she hugging the teddy bear?
I can't tell.
Make her dance.
We'll make you happy.
We'll make you happy!
Wait, does she also dance to this one?
It's a slower song.
No...
It's so sad.
Why does it kind of fit the mood?
Did Mint get the laughing octopus figurine?
I did!
I did, I did.
This...
The sound of this song reminds me of...
So one time I was in Akiba, and I was heading to a maid cafe, I think.
But my reservation wasn't yet.
And so, there was a...
There was a street live going on.
And I went and watched them, and they sounded a lot like this.
It totally obviously wasn't them, but...
I still have their CD, they're not active.
Their theme was so cool, because they were like an old school Japanese princess, and then a demon.
And their CD, I bought it.
It was half song and half drama CD.
And they had their own little world building that they did.
And it was so cool!
And they sounded so good!
I was like, I have to buy a CD, they sound so good.
Like, their moms were the ones that took my money.
I still listen to that CD.
But it's kind of a shame that they couldn't continue their activities.
Yeah, it was really cool.
I love finding street lives.
This is for you, Sunny!
Okay, follow the footsteps.
Okay, I actually need to pay attention.
Sorry, sorry for the music.
Sorry, music.
Sorry, Sunny.
I don't remember when the guys start coming in, so I don't want to get too, you know...
Too excitable, and then I...
Okay, so they go this way.
The trampled grass?
Is this trampled grass?
I can't tell.
Okay, thanks Otacon.
I will.
Sorry for your eyes again.
We are going!
They look the same.
This way, right?
Because it's...
They wouldn't let her go on her own.
It's gotta be this way.
Right?
Waste.
The trampled grass.
Oh my god!
That guy is peeing over there!
Where is my camera?
Wait.
How do I zoom in?
I actually saw him like real pee!
He was holding his ding dong while he did it.
Oh my god!
And he washed his hands!
What?
No, it's not.
Sorry.
Bad aim there.
I really...
I really didn't do that one so great.
Okay.
Night vision!
Oh no!
I can't tell!
I hate this part!
Hi!
It's this way, right?
Because there is two sets.
I can't.
I hate this part so much you guys.
I'm gonna be messing it up a lot.
I'm sorry.
I'm really not good at this part.
I see bugs and people.
What is that?
What's that right there?
This part is... I know people...
Some people don't like some scenes that happen further up in...
Sniff it!
Nasty!
It's definitely hers.
Hold on.
I know, but this is probably my least favorite part of the game.
I really don't like this part.
It's so confusing for me.
Am I going the right way?
I hope so.
Trampled grass!
Yeah, okay.
You can backseat here, you guys.
If I go the wrong way, you can be like, No, Mito!
Don't go that way!
And I'll be like, okay.
Thank you.
In fact, if you backseat here, I would really love it.
Are those guys or am I crazy?
I'm crazy.
Those look like crouching guys right there.
I don't remember where to go either.
That's all good.
Someone asked me...
Look at the butt.
Why does it look like two guys there?
Oh my gosh, hold on.
I feel like I'm insane right now.
I hate everything right now.
My camo is 35.
If he comes over here, I'm so caught.
Don't do it!
Alert, go down!
Faster!
Okay, he's retreating.
My literal stress.
My actual stress levels.
No, what?
I'm so angry.
I couldn't tell where they were.
Get in the dark.
They come through here.
Hold on, I'm gonna also...
Camouflage.
We're also gonna put on a face.
We're gonna be face camo.
There we go, 83.
Might be okay, actually.
I don't see anyone, but...
This is what we just picked up from laughing octopus.
Serious question.
In regards to both the frogs and the Beauty and the Beast unit, would you or not?
I think that's a silly question, right?
I think everybody here would say, yeah.
We are of yeah consensus.
Yeah.
Okay, sorry for the...
Alright, back to your regularly scheduled programming.
Are they coming through here?
What just happened?
What?
What was that?
Okay, if we're here...
Since I already got caught, I'm gonna be...
We're gonna have the face camo on.
Oh, truck doors.
We're gonna have the extra camo since I got caught just now.
And I feel like a dummy dumb.
Thinking that the damn wall with some guy is crouching.
Oh, there he is.
I can't get him from here.
Slow.
You go back to facing that way.
Yeah.
He lies down like my cat.
Okay, over a little.
I look like a cheetah.
You!
You bastard.
You got me before!
Oh gosh, my eyes.
Sorry everybody.
Seems to be this way?
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
They all look the same.
Naomi, you damn big ass bee.
I can't tell.
Yes, this way?
She got a big fee.
Master key?
That's sold for 9000.
Sorry snake, you're just gonna have to deal.
Oh gosh, I just realized our...
I'm looking for guys.
Looking around.
I didn't remember I think we went through the water, did we not?
No pee pee here.
Don't drink the water, snake.
Or there is, maybe.
Extra alert for pee pee man.
Okay, hold on.
Let's use a solid eye just in case.
Okay, looks like everything is going on over there, so...
Whatever is going on over there, so...
We're not gonna go that direction obviously.
We're gonna go through the water.
Peculiar.
This way?
I feel like there's gotta be someone leading her, you know?
She got princess carried.
What?
She's so needy, that one.
Wrong?
Left, okay.
Wait, what?
Oh, because I said just her footprints disappear.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Alright.
I see whoever is over there.
Stress is going down.
So needy, I know.
Alright, snake, you good?
You okay buddy?
Your eyes!
Shield!
So, forward.
Because they all converge.
They all go the same way.
Sure.
I don't know.
Sounded like her voice came from the right too.
It did!
So I'm not sure.
Unless they walked backwards with her.
She held them up and made them walk backwards.
Who's in the trees?
What's over here?
Do you see that on the radar?
Is there a person?
Maybe not.
Oh no,
there was.
Oh there definitely was!
Somewhere.
I have no idea where.
Hello?
Where at?
Whatever, just keep going.
Just keep on, keep on.
Come on, snake.
You got this.
You and your...
He was not on the radar.
That guy is not on the radar.
I think there is someone else coming up.
I can't tell.
The birds just flew so I feel like...
I don't know.
Wait, where am I going?
Am I going the right way?
Nice save.
Thank you.
The birds were disturbed.
I know, that's why I thought something was...
Hopefully I'm going the correct way.
That's a tree.
I can't believe that guy didn't show up though.
That's crazy.
I thought he was going to detonate it.
I thought he was going to lie down on it and detonate it.
Maybe it's a better thing that he didn't.
Why are these guys not showing up on my solid eye though?
Scary.
Wait, hold on.
Come on Mark 2.
There we go.
Thank you.
The guinea pigs!
They went separate ways here, right?
Sorry for your eyes again.
It's a little freaky.
This is actually so freaky.
Doesn't this lead to something?
I can't remember what it leads to.
Let's check it out.
We have the horde of guinea pigs here.
Death stranding reel, right?
It's a true death stranding moment.
Hello!
So cute!
It's actually kind of spooky.
It's pretty spooky but...
Get the camo.
You can get camo here?
Freaky!
I don't want that guy to wake up.
They're the cutest rodents.
Yeah, guinea pigs are pretty cute.
I don't think I've ever seen a wild guinea pig.
There's just some animals that are like hard to think about them being...
Like a wild animal, you know what I mean?
Sorry for your eyes once again.
Oh, just kidding.
So they split up here.
So this is probably hers, right?
To the left?
No?
Looks like... wait, I can't tell.
I don't know.
Because over there, there was a bunch of footprints.
To the right.
Who's calling me?
Think!
God!
God, think, Snake!
Naomi Hunter?
Well, that's really heavy footage.
Footprints, and then you have light footprints here.
I can't tell!
These are her shoes.
These are her shoes, but...
Some might say Jaeger.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Who just woke up?
From where?
Oh,
this guy.
Nevermind.
He's got two Z's.
I'll just do it anyway.
Who just woke up?
Me.
Hello?
Wait, I think someone's coming this way.
Oh, I think the froggies start coming.
Right?
Am I crazy?
Or I'm not sure.
Nevermind.
I don't know.
I thought some...
Okay.
So this way.
Right way.
Probably a frog with that voice.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
The froggies.
I'm marching along through the grass.
I'm not going very fast.
But I'll get there one day.
I'll rescue the lady and we'll live happily ever after.
I'm marching on through the grass.
I'm not going very fast.
But I gotta be swift.
I gotta be smart.
Or else she will die.
Sorry, rhyming is not my strong point.
I am super...
Gosh, you scared me Otacon.
Where did they go?
Is
someone coming up on me?
I don't know!
That doesn't look like...
I'm so lost.
Loud ass snoring.
I know, right?
Do these look like her?
Does the map help?
Not really.
And
then this is like...
They backtrack or something.
I hear a helicopter.
If
I get this guy, is someone else gonna be like...
We're going A-way.
We're going a direction...
That could be...
Correct?
Or...
Incorrect.
Oh my god.
I hate this part.
We're going A...
I feel like it's not this way.
You really like this part?
I feel like anybody who wants to be...
A Scooby-Doo mystery gang would really like this part.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like it's not this way because...
Because look, we could've gone two different ways then.
Right?
I feel like they're like, you wanna only go one way.
I feel like it's gotta be this little...
It's like a stomach, right?
Right here.
Yeah, you think so?
Okay.
Would you like a hint?
Yes!
I would love a hint.
Hint time!
Engage the timer or the inner Columbo.
Engage the timer, Columbo.
No hint.
It's not your stream!
Back to sleep.
Yawn, yawn, yawn.
You don't have anything for me?
Oh, I hear the helicopter.
Okay.
One of the footsteps are Naomi's.
Isn't the helicopter a good thing?
Isn't that where they meet up?
Is it like right over there?
Oh, I forgot to take off the mask.
We got Deadpool.
We should be close to the end of the act soonish, I believe.
I know there's like a chase...
There's like a scene with cars and...
Oh my
god, what are you doing with that guy?
You suck so much.
It's Vamp.
I'm sure of it.
We could snipe Naomi.
Let me play, please!
MGS3!
I wanna get her!
What would her name be?
The bitch.
Sorry, no.
It's not nice.
This is a cancer!
Too far.
Come on, take the shot!
Take the shot, Snake!
Get her straight through the eyes.
Straight in the middle.
Take the shot!
Run, person!
Snake, how could you miss?
Gosh, Vamp is such a freak.
Now he's got a second matching bullet hole.
Guys, Vamp is here.
Begin.
We'll use his blood.
It could get intense.
Brace yourselves.
Shots, all of you.
Yes, sir.
I'll be taking in half.
Oh my god.
Someone's mooing.
I'm not cut out to be a soldier, guys.
I could never take the shot.
Those shots.
I could take these shots.
Kill me.
Get a little closer to the edge of that door, would you?
Just gotta take a few more steps closer.
Third time Phil Lamarr got shot in the face.
What's this?
Oh no.
Snake!
Oh no!
You're so useful right now.
Barfing in a mask seems awful.
Oh gosh, I didn't even think about that.
That's horrible.
It's not working.
That guy just pooped blood or something.
What happened?
Or maybe I shot him.
Johnny moment reveal.
Oh gosh, not the cows!
Why is the helicopter not taking off yet?
Woah!
Pumpkin!
Step on it!
Alright, pick me up.
Gross.
Can you imagine if they just opened the helicopter?
Or they closed the doors while he's still down there and he just topples over inside.
Hi!
Rabbit!
Oh yeah!
Shoot those!
Yip!
Gecko.
Why?
Cow move.
Oh.
It doesn't sound...I don't hear the can you walk part.
I just hear walk.
It's like he's commanding her.
Don't let Otacon near her.
Don't let him talk to her at all.
Okay, I know the little mark 2 is cute, but don't let him...don't let him talk to her.
Walk.
Rio, walk.
Little monkey.
The monkey looks so satisfied.
So cute.
What is happening?
What?
Oh no.
There were few survivors.
Did the monkey drink from that first?
I think so!
Naomi.
She has...she's fine.
I got the PS2 MGS essential collection today.
Nice!
Alrighty.
This is what they mean by twin peaks.
Okay.
How do I shoot this thing?
Oh gosh.
Who's shooting me?
I did.
Yeah, I did.
Sorry, I have to shoot people.
I have to...Oh my god!
Okay, Otacon.
How about you do it then?
How about you do it then, Otacon?
Come on!
I...there's...
Is that the last guy?
Sorry.
Oh my gosh, there's still another one?
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
Back up!
I'm trying!
There's a guy hanging on for dear life.
What's the best part?
Oh my gosh.
Get off and fight that guy.
Yeah, get him off.
Okay, and back on.
Okay.
What's the best place to shoot them?
The legs?
Okay.
Nice!
Sorry guys.
We got too close.
I hear a guy being like...
Do I explode them or like...
We're just kinda rolling around on the ground here.
Oh, they do recover it seems.
Okay.
Understood!
Oh my gosh!
Go away!
You're welcome.
Can I hold
on?
That was the place to farm.
It must have been those guys in the back corner.
And then they would keep respawning.
And then I would get him.
And then...
I know where.
There's still...
Oh no!
A what?
Metal Gear Solid?
Shoot!
Oh no!
We got Metal Gear Solid on our butts!
Do I open this door?
Open up!
Yeah, I am.
I am.
I 100% am.
Okay, I'm getting two instructions at once man.
What do you want me to do?
I'm too slow to turn around.
I'm trying to turn!
The back seaters are back at it.
Stay away from that gate.
Oh, we got it.
I think he could've... I think he could've run into that.
I'm not gonna lie.
I think... I think he could've...
Yeah, turning is so clunky in this part.
He could've 100% run through that.
Woo!
When are they gonna make a Metal Gear Solid amusement park ride?
Speed!
I'll take down anything in our way!
What is that?
It's a log!
Oh gosh!
I'm trying to turn.
Oh god.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
Oh my god, this part is so icky.
I'm trying to turn!
Non-lethally removing guys from the APC.
Go to load with the caltrain blazer, right?
Yeah, exactly!
This is all non-lethal!
Baby!
I am you.
Oh my gosh, snake hold on.
This is what Cybertrunks are supposed to be.
Oh, ok.
That works.
Ok!
Hold on tight!
Oh my god, thank you Otacon!
I just think of him talking to snakes.
I'm not!
Don't fall off!
I know what's about to happen here.
No spoilers!
No spoilers everybody.
I love this part.
I know what's about to happen.
Take off the mask.
I will when I can.
That kind of sucks.
This part though, even with the mask, it's not what's the important thing.
I think.
Priorities.
Hey, you can't fight if you are dehydrated.
Time for peek.
I love that this monkey loves her.
The monkey is obsessed with Naomi.
It's just like the photo.
Oh my god.
It's so funny.
They are so cute.
I like the way they sound like cicadas.
What's that?
That's Minky in the middle.
I don't want to touch Naomi.
I'll get her cooties.
Oh my god, Naomi!
She's like, well technically yes I can move.
I'm just a little slow.
What did that have to do with her leg though?
They mean striker mobile gun system.
Perfect choice for a Metal Gear Solid game ironically enough.
Jack is back baby!
Yay!
Yeah!
Doctor!
I can definitely imagine seeing this scene and being like, I gotta play as Raiden.
He's so awesome!
I wish he had the knives in MBR.
He does have some knives, but yeah...
For like the short, the close combat.
Yeah!
Those are what we mean when we say grippers!
His high heels.
Raiden wears heels more than I do.
Oh!
There he is!
A boy!
He's so Bishounen.
I started to play MGS because of Raiden.
Okay, show's over.
This trailer for MGR was hype.
So real.
The stealth camera.
Why do they move?
I don't know, it's fun!
Lucky!
We gotta talk to our little pal over there.
To creep people out.
It's in the lore.
That's really the reason?
Oh, this is where I just run, isn't it?
Hold on.
Isn't this where it says it's time to run, right?
I think it's time to go.
Wait.
Time to go!
This is one crowded...Oh my goodness!
Lucky!
I'm running!
Oh my gosh...
He one shot me.
He one shot me!
Okay fine, we are back to old Snake.
I understood.
He's not keeping them busy enough!
Guys, not so great going on here.
Okay.
Let me do what I did before.
And I'm also gonna equip my ration instead.
And we're gonna do this.
Okay.
Face.
I wish I didn't have to keep taking the face camo off.
Alright, let's go!
Unless...I went the other way.
But
he like jumps right here, so I can't really like...it's hard to...
Further.
Okay.
I'm going!
Oh gosh.
Okay.
He kicked me into the cutscene!
That's the speedrun strats right there.
We take those!
Yes we do!
Speedrun Tag Reels!
Use the little...
I hate...I don't like that.
Why did you make that...
Why did you make that sound?
Touchdown Mito!
This guy is the ultimate freak.
I don't think anyone can outmatch this freak.
For real.
He's just actually...
No, I...I say that, but Ocelot literally exists.
No, not even my freak.
I swear.
Him and Ocelot should have a freak off.
But he seriously is just actually a freak.
Oh!
Nasty!
You're scratching the metal.
Oh my gosh, that's JerryRig's everything when he gets a new phone.
You too, Immortal.
No, I just don't fear death.
Here is my actual favorite part.
Let them...
He
does it again!
It's kind of sad we didn't have a breakdancing part in Revengeance.
Now that I think about it.
So freaky.
The tongue!
Ouchie, ouch.
Gross!
Crap.
This pose is...what's that movie?
What's that movie where the lady dances and then the water splashes all over her?
That's what I think of every time I see that scene.
Uh-oh.
Flashdance?
Is that it?
I think so, yeah.
At what point does it stop being...they're trying to kill each other.
At what point is it like...just a sexual tension?
Maybe the whole time.
Oh my god.
She's so romantic!
Now they are one.
Yeah,
keep hugging him like that.
What's laughing?
That's too much.
Oh.
Snake cover your innocent eyes.
The phrasing.
No!
He's spent.
What a show!
Again, again!
They got the beef.
Because Raiden is so different in this game, it's weird for me to think that that's the same Raiden from MGS2.
And all that fight, bam, the first time.
So that's why he's like, yeah, I know this guy and I hate him.
But it's hard to imagine that's the same guy.
Encore, baby!
You're not doing so well.
Oh my god, his nails.
They did not need to give him...I was about to say a French chip, but that's not what that is.
They did not need to give him that though.
They did though.
I love him.
I suffer brain damage from that fight.
Oh baby!
I'm dumb now.
Hey guys, I think I might be on the wrong site.
Oops,
all brain damaged.
Ew.
Oh god.
Oh god, Raiden.
Oh god, Raiden!
He's got to be immortal.
Naomi?
Naomi!
Got the Foxhound rank in Mv3!
Congratulations, Brian!
Brian!
Why the F were we not providing covering fire for him after we feed him?
That's a great question.
Europe.
Oh gosh.
Dies of cringe.
Wow, we got 10,000 dp for the flashback swatch.
Nice, nice, nice.
21 kills?
What?
Who did I kill?
We are at 380,000 drubbing points, everyone.
Shoot.
Could you please be more specific?
Raiden Europe doesn't say much.
Oh, from the vehicle segment.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
5 continues.
It should have been less.
After playing Rising Revengeance first, did you think Metal Gear could get any weirder?
I...
I understood so little of Revengeance that it's like...
I think, honestly, Rising is like...
Not even the peak weird.
Yeah, so it's like...
I don't...
Yeah, it definitely gets weirder.
That's me looking at my...
I have a little trading card of Raiden and his sombrero on my desk.
I keep it in my wallet, actually.
But I had it out, I don't remember why.
It's even sealed.
But, yeah, I don't know.
It's so funny, people reference Rising all the time.
But the whole core series is just so crazy and fun.
But Rising is a lot of fun to play.
When I play it again...
I'm gonna be honest, I'm probably gonna play it on easy mode again.
I don't wanna learn how to parry.
Save the game, yes.
Okay, so...
Maybe I do just farm in the later levels.
Hope you have fun, may you have a happy birthday!
Neo Cerberus, of course!
Aw, you could've interrupted.
It's not an interruption, it's all good.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Neo Cerberus!
Happy birthday!
It is a little frustrating that they cost so much money, but...
But I guess we'll survive, I suppose.
We're getting through the game anyway.
Okay.
And?
Do we get a briefing, and then we go into Act?
What's...
Clearing the game, no kills, no spots, doing that...
Oh, well...
No spots?
No, that's like...
Clearing the game, no kills is way easier than clearing the game with spots.
If you had to do the trolley problem and Naomi was on one track and Huey was on the other, what would you do?
I'm thinking.
This is how I make my eggs now.
This is the only good Naomi has ever done for me.
Yeah.
They cook on one minute?
She likes cooking eggs.
This is my sunny-side-up fortune-telling.
When it turns out good, it means something good is gonna happen.
So that's why you don't cook them over easy.
One minute.
The secret to good cooking is to keep who's going to eat it in mind.
Oh...
Sunny!
Me, I'm gonna eat it.
Yes.
Protactinium, uranium, neptunium, plutonium, americium.
What a show-off.
Curium.
Yeah, Sunny knows it.
You had to get help from a kid.
Oh, she likes the flower.
You did not need to step on the box for that, Naomi.
You know that.
She's half your size.
No, Sunny's so cute!
Don't teach her such a lesson at such a young age.
She looks beautiful no matter what she does.
Oh.
The eggs!
Take it off!
That was like 5 minutes.
I KNOW YOU'RE TAKING CREDIT FOR HER EGGS!
I CAN'T STAND YOU, NAOMI HUNTER!
KILL NAOMI!
SAVE YUI!
I WANT THIS BITCH DEAD!
If Naomi was part of 2, she would have killed Olga.
It's true!
Also, Snake!
What is that?
What is that down there?
Is that his PC?
Why do you just have a picture of Snake on your computer?
Well,
let me get closer.
Who are you?
What are you doing, Sonya?
Not where the food is made, Snake!
That's so horrible!
Oh, sorry.
I'm blocking the subtitles, I think.
You don't have a picture of Snake on your computer?
I absolutely do.
I have pictures of Snake everywhere.
GET AWAY FROM HIM!
GET AWAY!
Get away from him.
Get away!
Leave space between...
Hi,
Snake.
Are you okay?
I love when he wears this shirt.
He's literally my PFP.
Gosh, so loud in my head.
What?
Solidus is dead.
Solidus on the PC!
What?
IBS?
IBS!
Damn, I'm full.
The IBS is real!
Oh, IBS.
Oh, Raiden!
Are you okay?
Raiden.
Sleeping baby.
Big Boss don't have the same genetic code?
STOP TOUCHING HIM!
Snake!
Are you going to accept this?
Oh my God, he turns away.
No!
My heart!
He has the system completely under his control.
He's so foul.
I know!
What?
Dante, what?
It's not possible.
Oh.
Death.
I got your DNA now.
Europe.
SunnyCam.
His voice is so scary.
Are you okay?
Sunny is too busy hacking to care.
No!
The Patriots!
Yeah, you take it Sunny.
No, Snake!
They are so cute.
Slicking away when Raiden's screeching was going on.
I thought it was you screaming rabidly at Naomi.
You wouldn't be wrong probably.
It's one or the other.
Gosh, is it cold in there Snake?
I need to get you a bra or something buddy.
Snake!
I can't stop staring.
The light of the computer highlights them.
You're gonna take all the credit for her work.
She did most of the work and you're gonna press two buttons.
Sunny doesn't know how terrible of a woman she is.
It's okay.
What do you mean?
Look at this.
His artificial blood needs dialysis.
We don't have the proper equipment.
The doctor!
Dialysis?
Getting his wounds healed is important too.
But at this rate, he's not gonna last that long.
Oh no, Raiden!
Dialysis.
Is that like what kidneys do?
That's right.
She's so smart.
Raiden's blood is an older type of artificial blood that was used by the military.
Called white blood.
Why did they swap out his blood?
After it's been in use for a while, the blood needs to be dialyzed.
When did this happen?
That they just switched out his blood?
Right now, he's slipping into autotoxemia.
No!
Raiden!
Look at her big ol' eyes.
Since 2?
Cyborg blood is cool, eh?
Raiden, have you ever looked at a map?
Do you know how big Europe is?
Dr. Madnar!
He saved my life.
Dr. Madnar.
I've heard of him.
A world-renowned cybernetics expert.
Strictly underground though.
We're in luck then.
It's settled.
We must head for Europe.
The sooner we get there, the better.
I'll call Campbell and have him get us landing clearance.
It hurts.
It physically hurts.
This is a no-smoking flight.
Hurts my soul.
My chest gets tight.
Who's piloting this thing?
Who's driving this ship?
Look at how she plays with her feelings.
She's like a skinship.
What?
Why do you guys have all your pictures of your dead relatives on the computer?
What is going on?
What highlighter does she use?
It looks nice.
It's nice.
I hate
this part.
Don't act so kind to her.
You don't know anything about him!
I feel like I'm about to crash out.
I don't want to watch this.
I don't want to watch this anymore!
Leave him alone!
What?
Crash out is real.
In the books he says...
In the books...
In the books he says, in her monologue he says...
I only said that to seem cool, but I'm still an otaku.
He's still an otaku!
Otakai don't betray us!
No!
Isn't this heading home for you?
Naomi a little bit?
Really?
Sunny helped build this?
So in the end she did influence a death in two.
Wait, who?
Did you not see how smart she was earlier?
I'm going...
You don't even like Sunny!
You are faking liking her!
I need to walk away for a second.
I need to leave!
I need to leave.
I need to leave for a second.
She's always in there.
Searching for herself.
Searching for her family.
She's trying to find out who she is and where she's going.
I need to get back.
Searching for herself and her family.
She believes she can find the answers inside a machine hooked up to the world.
She spends every day inside the net exploring.
For Sunny, this is home.
No, it shouldn't be like that.
What?
It's time you let her go outside.
What are you talking about?
She hasn't even been born yet.
She's still a fetus.
She's still in the womb.
Oh my god.
She needs to live a real life.
But Sunny's never shown any interest in leaving the Nomad.
Frankly, I'm worried about all your gold.
Okay, this is the only thing I actually agree with.
With Naomi on...
The Otacon.
She's never shown interest.
Yeah, she doesn't...
She doesn't know anything else.
Give me something to break.
How about Naomi's face?
No, I refuse, Grass.
She's being so sussy.
Has Sunny never had a meal outside of eggs?
Has she ever had anything?
Is it okay to sleep in there?
Excuse me?
Well, Dr. Emmerich...
I know it's easy to forget sometimes, but I am a woman.
You understand.
Sorry.
I know it's selfish of me, but...
Sorry, the way he's covering his face.
I understand.
The way he's like...
Oh my goodness.
I need Naomi to ruin my life.
Liquid, solid.
I physically can't watch this, you guys.
I'm sorry.
I need to go.
I can't do this again!
Call me Hal.
Good night.
Good night, Hal.
Shut that door.
Lock it.
Open the door!
Open the hatch!
Push the plane out!
The helicopter out!
I actually shivered just now.
We're stronger now that we have gotten past the worst part of the game.
We are stronger individuals now.
We don't have to do it again.
But for those who have not seen that cutscene...
You had to see it.
You have to know how terrible of a person Naomi Hunter is.
I didn't understand why you hated her this much, but now I get it.
No, no, no.
You don't...
You don't even understand!
It gets worse!
Hi.
I wish I could go back in time and tell him to cut this character out of my afterlife!
Hottake, you should be hoping that Hal falls in love with Naomi given the established pattern with his love interests.
Yes, but also...
I don't want Otacon to have his little heart broken!
I don't want Otacon to be a sad guy!
Naomi is Gray Fox's fault.
You are right!
We need to go back in time.
We need to go back in time!
We need to tell...
We need to actually...
When Gray Fox...
After we fist fought Gray Fox in the minefield...
I say field, in the mine room...
Was that before or after?
Because I think we really need to finish the job there!
Is Naomi worse than Strangelove though?
Yes!
Million!
I love Strangelove.
Sorry, this is a strange... I actually really like her.
He already had Naomi.
We need to go back in time.
Even further!
We need to go back in time even further!
We need to make Gray Fox never join the military.
We need...
We need to make sure he just never...
He never steps foot in that office!
He never enlists!
He never does anything!
And then...
Then we'll... wait...
Who will kill... ok, wait...
Actually, we need to tell Gray Fox to finish the job!
This is his fault!
He killed her family but he didn't finish the job!
This is all Gray Fox's fault!
We need...
Wait, not a new save!
This begs the question, who's worse, Naomi or Huey?
Naomi for my personal bias, but honestly, I think Huey's way worse.
Naomi's worse in my personal bias, but she also did cause like a...
She's just... she caused a whole lot of drama and...
She just caused... she's like the Black Plague of this world.
She caused so much...
Just because she was like...
You killed my brother!
I can't believe you killed my brother!
I'm Naomi with my accent and you killed my brother!
And then...
And
then...
She's like...
She should be so far removed from the whole Patriots...
Everything situation, but no!
She just gotta get her little stinking nose in there.
She's gotta get her little nose.
She's gotta bury it deep in the shit.
She's just gotta be in everyone's business and then she takes the credit for everything!
She takes the credit for everything after sticking her nose into where it does not belong!
I swear!
She... just cut her out of the equation and it would solve so many problems!
End scene.
Anyway...
So you're saying you don't like her then?
Right here is the passion I started watching you.
I hope this has been cathartic for you.
I'm a person that when I get angry I cry.
Act 3!
In conclusion, still good.
Don't... stick it in crazy.
Everybody says that.
We're gonna skip this cutscene because I need to get to the title menu.
Skip, skip, skip!
We're not continuing.
I gotta get to the title menu.
But I can fix her.
You actually can't!
You actually...
can't!
Like you...
really...
You really cannot.
Oh my gosh!
Who is this handsome devil right here?
Can we have a poll on wood or wooden?
Absolutely not.
You okay now Mint?
If not, here's ice cream.
Thank you!
Fixing Naomi?
Level impossible.
Act 2 really just gets my blood boiling.
But Act 3 is a lore dump and a half.
Strap in for next time.
Lots of lore and craziness.
We get to learn a lot and get a lot of answers.
Thank you Fujo Crashout is why we love watching you never change.
I have the most feelings.
That's a lie.
If you think I have a lot of opinions, a lot of feelings about Naomi...
Maybe quadruple that and those are the feelings I have for Snake and Ocelot.
Thanks for the five gifted!
All I have to do is think about Snake and Ocelot and I'm immediately put into tears.
Only quadruple?
Well that's like the minimum.
It's like the minimum.
I love this song.
This title screen is so...
It really just has a lot of...
It really sets the tone.
It has so much emotion in it.
It's so good.
It's a core memory.
For me too.
Like I just hear this song and I'm like...
I just feel...
This game makes me feel everything.
I love this game.
I know it has so many criticisms.
And they're all valid.
Well, not all.
A lot of them are valid but...
Watch again next time on Myth Phantom Channel.
I just woke up.
Good morning, Nita!
It has its criticisms but I just...
I can't not love it.
I don't know.
I think it's such a good ending.
Snake!
Oh my god, the title screen!
This was a very entertaining stream.
I loved all the Naomi hate tonight.
I hope you have a good rest of your evening, YouTube Ireland!
Thank you guys for...
Act 2.
I'm gonna go eat some dinner.
And yeah.
Otsuminto!
Thank you guys.
Act 3.
I don't know if Act 3 will be Saturday or Sunday next weekend.
I'm trying to finalize some plans that I have.
But...
One of those...
One day.
It will be a day.
Salty0, thank you!
Thanks for the pink!
I had so much fun.
I love watching you play the MGS series.
Thank you!
And we got...
We got our second statue, so...
We're killing it, baby!
We'll get that solar gun.
And then we'll go outside and we'll go...
Solar!
Okay, farming stream.
Probably more towards the end we can do a farming stream.
I probably will do like a members...
Farming...
Something, something.
Yeah, sunlight!
That's what it is, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't forget to look up the extra passwords later too.
Yeah, I should, I should, I should.
Comment that.
Comment.
Put it in the comments.
Chiquito, so I don't forget, please.
Okay.
Otsumito, everybody!
Otsumito, Otsumito!
And I'll see you guys...
Next time!
Thank you!
Thanks for watching!
Bye-bye!